Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Sag mal, wann ist eigentlich dein nächster Zahnarzttermin?
Du wirst lachen, es ist tatsächlich morgen früh um 10.
Ach du Kacke, der ist, die Zahnärztin ist umgezogen.
Kein Scheiß!
Ninos, ich habe hier einen Job, den muss ich machen. Ich muss laut Lochbuch-Dance-Politik
Nummer der Sendung sagen und danach bist du dran.
Aber das ist meine Aufgabe hier. Deswegen trete ich an.
Gut, dass ich das mitbekommen habe.
Es ist immer gut, dass ich nachgefragt habe.
So ist das. Soll ich nochmal reinkommen?
Dr. Lipp hier. Naja, ok. Also.
Soll ich nochmal reinkommen?
Nee, war doch gut gesagt. Ja, kannst gerne nochmal reinkommen.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 471 vom 5. Oktober 2023.
Und nur hier werden die finalen Termine wirklich geklärt.
Hier kommt sozusagen alles zusammen. Das ist ein Fokuspunkt der Terminplanung
und überhaupt der Zeitordnung, könnte man fast sagen. Ja.
Ja.
Also das ist, ne?
Und während ihr das hört, sitzen wir beim Zahlen und lassen uns die Zähne machen
und ihr kriegt keinen Termin.
Ja, ja, wie war das, die Ausländer nehmen einem die Termine weg,
das ist ja in Berlin, in Berlin kannst du dich nicht mehr melden,
weil die Schwaben sich die ganze
Zeit hier einziehen und Meldetermine wegschnappen, so sieht's nämlich aus.
Ey das ist wirklich so erbärmlich.
Das ist wirklich so schwach, so weit unten der Typ ey.
Es ist schwierig mit den politischen Führern und ich muss auch sagen,
ich habe, ich spüre eine tiefe, tiefe schmerzhafte Müdigkeit,
wenn es um den täglichen deutschen politischen Diskurs geht.
Es geht mir schon seit einer Weile so, aber es ist irgendwie,
es wird immer schlimmer oder immer intensiver, dass ich einfach wegschaue von
den ganzen Schlagzeilen.
Ich hab dieses hin und her und dieses hick hack und dieses er hat gesagt und
aber hier und das falsche Wort und Also nicht nur im deutschen politischen Diskurs,
auch auf den von uns schon besprochenen und auch in dieser Sendung nochmal angesprochenen
sozialen Medien geht's mir auch so, die ganze Aufregung über alles,
alle regen sich immer auf, okay zugegeben.
Das regt mich auch auf.
Wir regen uns hier auch auf. Ja, aber wir sind wenigstens lustig dabei.
Wir sind jetzt echt nicht in der Position, dass das stimmt.
Ja, aber wach ein bisschen drumherum. Die anderen sind alle so bierernst.
Ja, und der Rest, der kann einfach nur mal so...
Ach, die zählen ja nicht auseinander. So. Und dann immer dieses links und rechts
treten und immer auf die Schwachen. Das ist schlimm.
Insofern ist es schon ein Wunder, dass ich diese Zahnarztnummer überhaupt mitbekommen
habe, weil die ist so an mir vorbeigeflogen und ich dachte mir auch so,
willst du wissen, was er gesagt hat? Nee, ich will's eigentlich gar nicht.
Ja, weil natürlich willst du wissen, was so ein F... also das ist einfach eine...
Nein, das ist dümmste, unterste Hetze und das ist halt nun mal leider nicht
irgendeiner, das ist der Typ, der sich...
Also wenn er die nochmal halbieren will, dann haben die 40 Prozent.
Aber das schafft doch noch mehr Aufmerksamkeit. Verstehst du?
Das ist doch genau wie diese so, oh, er hat Jehova gesagt und irgendwie dies
gesagt und wie kannst du nur und so weiter. Und das ist genau die Methode,
mit der solche Kommentare dann auch vervielfältigt werden.
Wenn sowas einfach nebenbei, nebendäufig irgendwie ist und alle ignorieren das,
aber jetzt diskutiert wirklich ganz Deutschland darüber.
Ich meine, ich hab letztens, was war das, du bist zufällig an so einem Fernseher
vorbeigegangen, da war da der, wie heißt der, Schruppaller da,
der Führer da, der hat, der sitzt da im Fernsehen.
Der Führer? Der Führer sitzt im Fernsehen?
Ist das nicht der Führer? Nee, der sitzt da, ist doch ein Honk.
Wer ist denn das?
Und Schrupp Haller, Tino Schrupp Haller,
irgendein AfD Honk, sitzt da bei Maischberger im Fernsehen,
ja, und dann war irgendwie Thema war Demokratie oder sowas, Was auch,
ist ja auch völlig egal, was das Thema der Sendung ist, der redet ja eh den gleichen Scheiß, ja.
Und dann sitzt der da im öffentlich-rechtlichen Systemfernsehen,
ja, und erzählt irgendwie, dass man in diesem Land seine Meinung nicht mehr sagen dürfte, ja.
Und du denkst dir so, Alter, du bist gerade in einem Fernsehsender,
also nicht in einer Live-Sendung, ja, Aber der zumindest durch Zwangsgebühren
finanziert ist und darfst deine Scheiße verbreiten und darfst vor allem eine
solche Scheiße verbreiten und in jedem Land,
wo man keine Meinungsfreiheit hat, darf man genau das nicht sagen, dass es keine gäbe, ja?
Und dann sitzen da alle und sagen, ja, können sie das vielleicht kurz vertiefen?
Was wäre die richtige Antwort darauf?
Ja natürlich muss man den dann fragen, wie er das meint und ob er das bitte
erläutern möchte, ob er vielleicht ein Beispiel sagen könnte und dann,
dann wird da irgendwie so dumm rumgeräumt.
Da hast du noch ganz genau, dass man in diesem Land, es gibt ja eine ganze Menge
Dinge, die ich hier nicht sagen darf, deswegen werde ich die jetzt hier auch
nicht sagen und dann sagst du so, schauen Sie, ich sag's nicht und deswegen
gibt's hier, es ist einfach auf einem geistigen Niveau.
Hat er gesagt? Das hat er gesagt?
Ja, so sinngemäß. Er hat auf jeden Fall nicht gesagt, was man nicht sagen darf,
weil man darf es ja nicht sagen. Ist ja klar.
Ich hätte ja gesagt, ach Herr Schrupalla oder wie sie heißen,
sie können ihre Meinung nicht sagen.
Wessen Meinung äußern sie denn jetzt gerade?
Das verstehe ich jetzt nicht. Ich glaube, der hätte die auf jeden Fall auch nicht verstanden.
Naja, also wenn er seine Meinung nicht äußern darf, aber er die ganze Zeit redet.
Ja, nee, aber er wollte natürlich betonen, dass es in diesem Land keiner mehr gibt.
Es ist doch, dass man in diesem, das wahrscheinlich plagt ihn,
dass man bestimmte Symbole und Slogans,
die ihm sehr auf dem Herzen liegen, hier nicht sagen darf und dass man,
wenn man irgendwie auf dem Niveau von dem, wie heißt der, Eiwanger da agiert,
dass man dann auch Konsequenzen tragen muss für die Scheiße,
die man labert oder dass eine Reihe Menschen Konsequenzen fordern,
Bis man irgendwie 25 Fragen von Söder mit,
was weiß ich, mit Hingerotzt beantwortet, ohne sie zu beantworten und dann rehabilitiert
ist, weil bald Bayernwahl ist.
Klar, deswegen sagt er das und deswegen möchte er auch diese Aufregung drüber
rum und am besten noch, dass sich alle total drüber aufregen,
aber ich würde halt irgendwie genau anders einschreiten und sagen so,
ach das ist ja interessant, wessen Meinung sagen sie denn jetzt hier die ganze Zeit?
Das war ja der Punkt, das versuchte ich ja gerade wiederzugeben,
dass er selbstverständlich von sämtlichen dort Anwesenden, ich glaube, das war in dieser...
Ich weiß noch nicht mal in welcher Sendung das war.
Ist ja auch egal. Er sagt ja immer das gleiche.
Natürlich haben sie ihm gebeten seine Behauptung zu erhärten und natürlich ist
er das schuldig geblieben. Es ist immer das gleiche Theater und das traurige
ist doch Tim, was man einfach mal leider so konstatieren muss.
Wenn jetzt irgendjemand wüsste, also wenn es, wenn es, wenn ein Kraut oder eine,
Kommunikationsstrategie gegen deren dummen Strategien gewachsen wäre,
ja, dann käme die ja zur Anwendung.
Dann würden wir ja hier nicht sitzen und mit offenen Augen staunen,
was für ein Quatsch diese AfD-Leute reden, was für ein hanebüchenen Unsinn und
Verbrechen Donald Trump begeht und damit durchkommt.
Wenn es so einfach wäre, dass Tim Pridloff eine gemeine Gegenfrage stellt,
dann würden wir das ja tun.
Also du weißt ja, dass gegen diese Vöglein aktuell zumindest nicht wirklich
ein sinnvolles Kraut gewachsen zu
sein scheint. Zumindest nicht auf dem Nährboden, den wir ihnen bereiten.
Ja, in Form von Menschen, die ausreichend Erfahrungen in ihrem Leben gemacht
haben, dass sie inzwischen lieber solchen Leuten zuhören als anderen,
um das mal kurz zu fassen.
Ach ja, ich bin enttäuscht. Du traust mir nicht zu, dass ich eine gute Frage
stellen kann, die ihn komplett aus der Spur bringt.
Nee, das traut ihr nicht zu Tim. Also ihn schon, der kommt natürlich sofort aus der Spur.
Der ist ja schon durch die erste Nachfrage aus der Spur gekommen und hat zurückgeschaltet
auf irgendwie wissentlich smart grinsen und irgendwie sagen sie wissen doch genau wovon ich rede.
Natürlich ist der sofort aus der Spur gekommen, sorry natürlich,
du kannst den auch einfach fragen fünf mal fünf, dann ist der auch aus der Spur.
Nur der hat halt, trotzdem ist er jetzt sag ich mal vor seiner,
vor den Leuten, die er da beeindrucken muss, als klarer Sieger aus dieser Interaktion herausgegangen.
Wir sind einfach diese hochbezahlten Interviewkräfte, die schlagkräftig genug,
also das ist irgendwie, ich finde die müssten irgendwie mehr können für ihr Geld,
dafür finde ich das alles zu viel,
also für die Performance finde ich zu viel, wo sind die klugen Fragen irgendwie,
frag doch mal, es gibt doch genug Klassiker und dann haben sie aufgehört ihre
Frau zu schlagen, das sind Fragen.
Das ist wirklich keine kluge Frage. So.
Weil das, da kannst du nur falsch drauf antworten, ich seh auch egal,
auf jeden Fall mich langweilen diese Leute, ich glaube da gibt es eine relativ
einfache Antwort, die in den meisten Fällen hoffentlich wahr ist.
Und die lautet ich habe meine Frau noch nie geschlagen.
Okay gut.
Also es wäre jetzt so.
Das ist doch die einzige.
In meinem Fall, ich glaube ich würde einfach sagen, ich habe keine Frau.
Jetzt machst es dir aber ein bisschen einfach.
Das macht eine ganze Menge im Leben ziemlich einfach.
Ja ja jetzt sag doch, dass es die Wahrheit ist und so. Das führt doch alles zu nichts.
Okay komm, machen wir hier Feedback.
Genau, bleiben wir bei der CDU. Aber jetzt geht es erst mal um unsere Verfehlung
hier Wolfgang Kommentiert korrekt Nicht die FPÖ ein Klammern blau Die ÖVP ist in Österreich türkis,
ein Klammern vormals schwarz Umgefärbt worden.
Ja wir haben die ganze Zeit FPÖ gesagt.
Ich habe es wirklich, also ich auf jeden Fall. Ja ich auch Ich auch,
wir sind beide schuld. Also es ist wirklich peinlich Ich weiß nicht,
mich hat dieses türkis schon immer total verwirrt.
Das ist ja auch nicht türkis, das ist kardenavia blau.
Cut the Nacho.
Carpaccio Grün, auf jeden Fall hat der, weißt du was,
also ich sprach da mit meinem Vater drüber und sagte hör mal hier hast du gesehen CDU neue Farben,
Kaliningrad blau und Rumdorf ja und weißt du was der gesagt hat,
ach ihr beide maler Adenauer, du wusstest das sofort.
Also du hast nicht Kaliningrad gesagt sondern du hast das richtige gesagt.
Ich hab das richtig gesagt ja ich wollte ich wollte aber ich wollte ich wollte
ihn mit meinem in unserer sendung recherchierten wissen beeindrucken,
und ihm sagen weißt du was ich gegoogelt habe mit dem tim in der sendung bei
uns in unserem bildungsprogramm ja was war das,
neues wissen in die welt trage damit wollte ich ihn beeindrucken und er sagte,
Ach, Adenauer, ich sag das wusstest du?
Ja sicher, in Röndorf hat der gewohnt und in Carpaccio hat der immer Urlaub gemacht.
Weißt du, was ich mich aber, weißt du, worauf ich mich freue?
Wenn die das nächste Mal die Farben ändern und dann irgendwie sowas wie Saumagenbraun oder sowas.
Das wäre schön.
Naja, auf jeden Fall lagen wir total daneben. Weiterer Kommentar kommt von Jonas.
Er schreibt, im Designstudio hat ein Prof immer den Witz gemacht,
wenn eine Gruppe, Design by Committee, Designentscheidungen trifft,
wird es am Ende immer blau.
Wie furchtbar muss das hier gewesen sein, wenn am Ende zwei Blautöne dabei herauskommen.
Ist das ein Witz? Wenn eine Gruppe Design-Entscheidung trifft,
ist es am Ende immer blau.
Also es ist witzig, aber es klingt für mich so ein bisschen wie Erfahrung.
Also das ist das, was der Prof gesagt hat.
Ja ja, aber warum blau?
Weil das irgendwie die Farbe des Kompromisses ist.
Wo ist hier die Pointe?
Die Pointe?
Also wäre der Witz auch witzig mit grün?
Naja, die Pointe ist, dass es ja gleich zwei Blautöne geworden sind. Nicht nur einer.
Ja, aber den Witz hat ja nicht der... Achso, der Witz geht...
Ja, jetzt hast du es auch langsam, ne? Also der Prof hat nur gesagt,
es kommt Blau bei raus und dann geht der Kommentar von Jonas Walter und er meint,
wie furchtbar muss das hier gewesen sein. Wenn am Ende zwei blaue Töne dabei herauskommen.
Ja, aber er sagt, das wäre ein Witz von dem Professor gewesen.
Es ist doch jetzt...
Für mich wäre ein Witz das, Jonas. Jonas, du machst bessere Witze als dein Prof.
Ja, vielleicht war es ja auch kein...
Witz sondern mehr so eine so eine tiefe Erkenntnis, dass halt meistens bei solchen,
ich meine hast du schon mal in so einer Jury gesessen oder in so einem Komitee,
was irgendwas beschäftigt, hast du doch bestimmt auch schon mal gemacht und
lass mich raten wie deine Erfahrung war, du bist genervt und du willst es nie
wieder tun, weil es einfach kein wirklich kreativer Prozess ist,
an dem irgendwas ordentliches mal rauskommt, ja,
Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich nie an irgendwelchen Wettbewerben teilnehme,
wo Jurys oder irgendwas entscheiden, weißt du, ich war einmal in der Jury, es ist so furchtbar.
Ich kann da jetzt gar nichts zu sagen, Tim. Du weißt auch genau,
wieso ich da jetzt überhaupt nichts zu sagen kann.
Recht weiß ich? Naja, ist ja egal. Auf jeden Fall. Du weißt es sehr genau.
Ja gut, aber du teilst, also du kannst nachvollziehen, was mein Erfahrungssatz andeuten möchte.
Ich habe aber jetzt Design by Committee gegoogelt, da sind mal so ein paar Beispiele abgebildet.
Hauptsächlich Fernbedienung mit 78 Knöpfen und der Pontiac Aztec,
was wirklich ein Fahrzeug ist, was sehr gute Chancen hat, einfach mal das hässlichste
Fahrzeug zu sein, was ich je gesehen habe. Siehst du das?
Das ist so scheiße. Und diese Fernbedienungen sind wirklich krass.
Geil, ne?
Und die haben, ey, und weißt du, nein, jetzt Tim, pass auf, guck auf diese Fernbedienungen.
So, okay, es sind nur zwei unterschiedliche Modelle, aber eines besticht mit blauen Tasten.
Gut.
Und da schließt sich der Kreis. Jetzt habe ich verstanden, was Jonas uns sagen wollte.
Genau, also Design by Committee ist ein bisschen.
Ist dieses Auto hässlich? Ist das ein Fehlauto?
Also im Wesentlichen drückt dieser Begriff aus, dass einfach kein Plan da ist.
Es gibt keine übergreifende Idee, der irgendwie allen Leuten folgen würde.
Das ist kein wirklich kreativer Prozess, sondern am Ende will nur jeder.
Jeder will an irgendwas beteiligt gewesen sein, jeder will irgendwie einen Button.
Ja, ne, aber ich sag nur ja, wenn jetzt auch noch der Exit Button ist und der
Enter und wir brauchen noch Return. So und das ist ...
Gutes Design erkennt man daran, dass es eine Person gemacht hat.
Ja ich wollte es andersrum drehen, also wenn du was findest,
was gut designt ist, dann ist es oft etwas, wo man es einfach einer sehr kleinen
Gruppe überlassen hat, darüber zu entscheiden.
Wenn du etwas findest, was gut designt ist, hast du den Boden der Demokratie verlassen.
Wo bleibt der Pluralismus.
So, dann gab es noch einen Hinweis von, wen interessiert es?
Adenauer als strammen Antifaschisten zu bezeichnen ist vor dem Hintergrund seiner
Haltung zu alten Nazis nach 1945, rechte Hand Globke, man kann kein schmutziges
Wasser wegschütten, solange man kein sauberes hat, problematisch bis schlicht falsch.
Nach 1945 war dann der adenauerische Antikommunismus deutlich stärker ausgeprägt
als ein etwaiger Antifaschismus.
Vor 1945 war ja Anti-NS und das ist nicht dasselbe.
Antifa ist Pseudo-Linker-Jargon, weiter nichts.
Also ich glaube es geht hier um die Stelle, wo ich einfach laut lache,
als ich Konrad Adenauer als stramm Antifaschisten bezeichne.
Mehr als laut lachen kann ich an der Stelle nicht machen, aber ich würde trotzdem
gerne hier zu zwei Aspekten kurz Bezug nehmen, Weil da mögen mich jetzt auch
gerne Historikerinnen korrigieren, aber ich glaube...
Das so verstanden zu haben. 1945, Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs und Ende des Nazi-Regimes
in Deutschland und Geburt zweier neuer Staatswesen.
Einmal der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, einmal der Deutschen Demokratischen Republik
unter sozialistischem Vorbild.
Beide hatten das Problem, dass sie nun mit den übrig gebliebenen Menschen einen
neuen Staat bauen mussten.
Und dass nach meinem Verständnis auf beiden Seiten nicht ausreichend,
sagen wir mal, demokratisch geschultes Material mit Führungserfahrung zur Verfügung stand.
Du hattest einfach jeder Mensch, der vielleicht, oder die überwältigende Mehrheit der Menschen,
die bestimmte Kompetenzen, die man für ein Staatswesen braucht,
sagen wir mal Lehrerinnen und Lehrer, Polizistinnen und Polizisten,
Beamte und Beamtinnen jeder Führungsebene und Kompetenz, konnten diese Kompetenzen
ja nur unter den Nazis erlangt oder unter den Nazis perfektioniert haben.
Oder davor.
Ja, dann eben, das meine ich mit perfektioniert, weil wenn sie es davor erlangt
haben, dann haben sie es quasi am Ende ihrer Karriere mindestens zwölf,
13 Jahre für die Nazis gemacht.
Also so oder so gab es da wenig Material, mit dem man jetzt ein unbeflecktes
Staatswesen hätte hochziehen können.
Das ist, glaube ich, erstmal eine Tatsache, die mit,
man kann kein schmutziges Wasser wegschütten, solange man kein sauberes hat,
halte ich, ohne jetzt den genauen Kontext zu kennen, das Zitat höre ich zum
ersten Mal, muss ich tatsächlich auch sagen, halte ich für eine vermutlich halbwegs
adäquate Erfassung des damaligen Zustandes.
Was sich ja dann im weiteren Verlauf entwickelt hat, ist, dass es unmittelbar
vom Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs überging in den sogenannten Kalten Krieg.
Kampf der zwei Systeme, Sowjetunion auf der einen Seite unter kommunistischer.
Wie soll man das sagen? Die ein kommunistisches Weltbild propagiert haben,
um nicht sagen zu müssen,
sie hätten eins umgesetzt und einen real existierenden Sozialismus geschaffen
haben und sich im unmittelbaren Systemkampf mit den USA befunden haben,
die ein kapitalistisch-liberal-demokratisches Modell propagiert haben.
Das heißt, die Bundesrepublik Deutschland hat sich sofort mit einem Systemgegner
wiedergefunden und wie wir wissen,
endet diese Auseinandersetzung mit nichts anderem als dem,
wenn ich es mal etwas übertrieben ausdrücke, Sieg des kapitalistisch-demokratischen
Systems und der Einverleibung der Deutschen Demokratischen Republik.
Was ja für die Reihe an Spannungen, die heute noch unsere Gesellschaft belasten, verantwortlich ist.
Das nämlich dann den vielen Menschen,
die in der Deutschen Demokratischen Republik geprägt wurden,
auch heute noch sehr unwohle Gefühle gibt, was also ihr Willkommen und die sogenannte
Wiedervereinigung betrifft.
Dass aber der Adenauer stärker antikommunistisch war, als in diesem Fall jetzt
nachher antifaschistisch, denke ich, erklärt sich einfach durch seine Position.
Er musste antikommunistisch sein, weil er sich in einem kalten Krieg wiedergefunden
hat, so ungefähr mit der deutschen demokratischen Republik unter strenger Führung
der USA, die alles angeguckt haben, dass er bloß alles gegen den Kommunismus tut.
Und gleichzeitig konnte er sich keinen strammen Antifaschismus leisten,
weil er seine Bundesrepublik da mit den ganzen alten Nazis bauen musste.
Also das sollten jetzt nicht entschuldigen, aber zumindest mal in einen historischen
Kontext rücken, der ja dann 68 ordentlich aufgemischt wurde.
Wohlgemerkt in dem Fall dann 23 Jahre später, wo,
jetzt machen wir mal ein bisschen Mathe, genau die Leute,
die jetzt in dem Alter waren oder langsam in dem Alter sein konnten,
in die Eliten aufzusteigen, Anlass hatten eine ausreichende Menge darzustellen,
auch zu kritisieren, dass da überall noch Nazis sitzen.
Also so habe ich das irgendwann mal mir zusammengeräumt oder wurde es mir erklärt.
Ja und ehrlich gesagt, also abgesehen davon, dass es für uns sehr schwer ist,
uns in die Situation eines Adenauers, der ja sozusagen noch im 19.
Jahrhundert groß geworden ist, zu versetzen, ja. Und vor allem auch nach dieser
Zeit. Und natürlich war er Anti-Nazi.
Er ist ja von den Nazis auch verfolgt worden und hat sich versteckt und so weiter.
Aber natürlich, hier Wehne interessiert es auch spezifisch, dass er sagt,
er war Anti-NS, aber nicht nennenswerterweise Antifaschist.
Genau, und man kann jetzt über den Begriff tatsächlich diskutieren,
was der ausdrückt oder so, ja, aber ich meine, den Nazis zu unterstellen,
sie wären Faschisten, das passt jetzt, glaube ich, erstmal ganz gut.
Und ich würde dann aber auch noch einen Schritt weiter gehen und sagen...
Auch dieser Kommunismus war ja in seinem Kern faschistisch,
ja der hatte irgendwie eine andere Farbe, aber am Ende waren da die Menschen
und die Freiheit und die Meinung genauso wenig wert.
Und von daher ist es halt ein Kampf an vielen Fronten, der immer noch,
auch heute noch geführt werden muss.
Man kann Labels draufpacken, man kann das irgendwie rechts und links und mit
irgendwelchen Kattenatschia Farben versehen, dieses ganze politische Spektrum.
Aber am Ende lässt es sich schon darauf reduzieren,
also entweder man ist halt wirklich für eine wirklich freiheitliche demokratische Grundordnung,
wie es so schön heißt, oder man verfolgt halt irgend so eine Agenda,
die im Wesentlichen darin besteht die Leute zu belügen, gegeneinander aufzuhetzen
und irgendwie zum Gewinn weniger sich gegenseitig zerstören zu lassen.
Er hat FDGO gesagt, das hat dir fünf Kommentare garantiert. Ich kann dir jetzt
schon sagen, wer kommentiert.
Ja gut, aber ich meine ich habe ehrlich gesagt nichts gegen eine freiheitlich
demokratische Grundordnung,
ich finde das ist irgendwie ein erstrebenswerter Zustand,
den kann man irgendwie schon erhalten und da war ich eigentlich auch,
da bin ich auch gut mit gefahren, ja ich meine ich bin ja ein Kind und du auch,
ich bin auch ein Kind ja, wir der Zeit in der wir sozusagen die Früchte dieser
Vorarbeit auch genießen konnten.
Klar man kann sich über dieses und jenes beschweren und Dinge werden auch schlimmer,
andere Dinge werden allerdings auch immer besser,
aber unser momentaner Gesamtzustand und auch die Zeit in der wir beide groß geworden sind,
auch wenn es eine leicht andere Zeit war, so war frei von viel dieser Umstände,
die die generationen vorher haben erleiden müssen von daher war das durchaus
schon mal eine erfolgsmeldung ja soviel zu meiner bodenständigkeit muss das
ja auch sagen mehr deutscher geworden jetzt.
Und als deutscher weißt du natürlich auch einfach ganz klar wofür cabaletta blau steht.
Klar das war irgendwo in Frankreich oder?
Ja.
Sind wir denn schon hier mit unseren Feedbacks zu dem Thema durch?
Ja, nein also ja da zu dem Thema sind wir durch aber noch nicht vollständig.
So, da haben wir uns ganz viel über Social Media unterhalten,
wie schon angedeutet, machen wir auch gleich nochmal ein bisschen.
Luca schreibt zum Thema unsoziale Medien. Bisher sehe ich das Killer-Feature
von BlueSky noch nicht, dass X ablösen kann.
Für mich wirkt es bisher wie ein Twitter-Klon ähnlich zu Jack Dorsey finanziert,
womit wir beim eigentlichen Thema des Kommentars wären.
Er möchte darauf aufmerksam machen auf das Protokoll Nostre,
das ebenfalls von Jack Dorsey finanziell unterstützt wird, aber parallel entwickelt
wird in Open Source, ist darauf aufmerksam geworden.
Bin ich vor einigen Monaten durch etwas known, der einen langen öffentlichen
Schlüssel in seine Twitter-Bio stellte und dann kommt da so ein Kino-Künscher.
Key, Nostre heißt Notes and Other Stuff Transmitted by Relay und ist eigentlich
nur ein wenig JSON, das durch Websockets an einen Server, der wahrgesendet wird,
je nachdem welche Attribute man mit dem JSON-Objekt auf dem Server...
Technik so bisher nutzen überdurchschnittlich viele Krypto Schreihälse Nostre
scheinbar zieht eine neue Plattform solche Leute immer als erstes an, was schade ist.
Okay ich hab das jetzt gerade gelesen und dachte so okay willst du mich jetzt
gerade davon überzeugen oder?
Aber dieser Jack Dorsey, also der ja der ehemalige Twitter Chef war,
der Mitgründer, der ist ja auch ein bisschen weird,
also das ist ja auch so eine Person von der man nicht so genau weiß was man
von ihr halten soll, aber der steckt halt auch irgendwie in dieser ganzen Crypto
Bubble mit drin und hat ja letzten Endes diesen ganzen Deal auch mitgetragen
von Elon Musk, er ist ja auch noch beteiligt an Twitter.
Und also hat sozusagen nicht verkauft, also hat bestimmte Anteile nicht verkauft,
sondern behalten, ich kann den nicht einschätzen,
aber es wird ja jetzt sozusagen behauptet, Blue Sky wäre jetzt sozusagen sein
Ding, der ist halt tatsächlich mehr auf dieses Nostra gerade abgefahren und
Blue Sky hat er zwar mal initial mit finanziert aber mittlerweile ist das andere.
Andere finanziers.
Dazu kann ich nur ergänzen, mit Sicherheit gibt es, also ich hab mir dieses
Nostro jetzt mal gerade kurz angeschaut, sieht ja irgendwie vielleicht gar nicht so uninteressant aus.
Es gibt ja eine ganze Reihe an irgendwie Social Media Protokollen und mach das
mal dezentral, mach das mal zentral und so weiter.
Und sicherlich würde ich sagen, dass bisher nicht das beste Protokoll gefunden wurde,
beziehungsweise sicherlich gibt es viele Leute, die der Überzeugung sind,
dass sie das Beste gefunden haben und dass es Bessere gibt, aber das ist eben
nicht das, was ein soziales Netzwerk ausmacht, sondern ein soziales Netzwerk
macht aus, welche Leute da drin sind.
Wenn ich Twitter ausgewählt hätte
nach der Art der Implementierung oder so oder der Art des Protokolls,
dann wäre ich im Zweifelsfall niedergelandet und so wird auch leider nicht die
Art des Protokolls oder die technische Implementierung die Entscheidung darüber fällen,
was potenziell an Twitters Stelle tritt oder was jetzt noch von Twitters Niedergang profiliert.
Mastodon hat ja schon mal relativ gut profitiert, Frage ist,
konnte das halten, sind die Menschen dort geblieben, haben sich neue Netzwerke
gebildet und das scheint so ein bisschen abgeflaut zu sein.
Also man liest jetzt zunehmend auf Mastodon von Leuten,
die, sagen wir mal, sich da nicht über die Implementierung des Protokolls oder
wo irgendein Knopf ist, beschweren, sondern die ein bisschen vielleicht ihre
Unzufriedenheit mit den dort zu erhaltenden Inputs ausdrücken.
Was ja einfach eine Unzufriedenheit mit den Menschen ist, die sie dort umgeben
oder der Kultur, die die Menschen dort pflegen.
Das ist jetzt eine Sache, die ich irgendwo mal gelesen habe.
Sorry, bevor jetzt wieder irgendwelche Mastodon-Fans sich darüber beklagen,
dass ich das schlecht reden würde. Es ist tatsächlich so, dass ich meinen Mastodon-Account
gerade am ehesten benutze und pflege. Ja, aber...
Wie wir in der letzten Sendung ja schon angesprochen haben gibt's ja jetzt diese Blue Sky Welle und wie,
das ist, da siehst du die Leute, die Leute meandern jetzt irgendwie gerade durchs
Netz auf der Suche nach einer geilen Party oder einer geilen Location,
ja doch, nach einer geilen Party und die Location ist bei einer geilen Party eben zweitrangig.
Boah geil, ey voll das Partywissen Tim.
Ich bin gerade voll überzeugt von meinem klugen Gedanken.
Ja, ich weiß, ich würde es trotzdem etwas einschränken wollen.
Also grundsätzlich hast du natürlich recht, die Community bestimmt,
was letzten Endes der Erfolg ist.
Ich würde jetzt nicht so weit gehen, dass ein Protokoll oder sagen wir mal das
Design dieses Systems da nichts zubeiträgt,
weil es ist natürlich schon so, dass bestimmte Dinge dann auch dazu geführt haben,
dass Twitter zum Beispiel so beliebt war, das sind dann auch Features,
die die User ja auch selber gebracht haben, dieses ganze Ad-Mentioning,
das Follow-Modell, das muss man ihnen geben, das haben sie selber gebaut,
das war eigentlich so die Basis des Erfolgs.
Aber so Menschen, wie das funktioniert und all diese ganzen Feinheiten,
das hat dann schon in den ersten Jahren dazu beigetragen, dass das dann eben
auch spannend wurde zu diskutieren.
Das sind halt so Mechanismen, die haben sich mittlerweile herausgebildet und
jetzt glaube ich bei der Twitter Nachfolge, hat es auch eine Menge damit zu
tun, wo sich die Leute so heimisch fühlen und während Mastodon halt.
Ähnlich ist aber auch an manchen stellen explizit dinge bewusst anders macht
ja hat bluesky teilweise andere design entscheidungen gefällt die jetzt manchen
vielleicht mehr zusagen.
Und von sich von daher dort wohler fühlen das ist für jede gruppe ein bisschen
anders und so weiter am ende ist natürlich immer entscheidend gibt es irgendwann
mal diesen netzwerkeffekt gibt es irgendwann so ein kipppunkt,
Wo so ganze Communities, also so viele,
wie nennt man dann diese Leute, das hab ich fast Führer gesagt,
also, populäre Gestalten oder so Zentren,
Community Zentren, so zentrale Personen bestimmter Communities,
wenn die halt irgendwie sichtbar abmarschieren und sagen ich probier jetzt das
aus, dann ziehen die natürlich eine ganze Menge nach sich und wenn diese Sogwirkung
stark genug ist, dann kann es dann halt auch schnell mal kippen.
Und ist ja ganz klar ich meine warum warum lese ich jetzt noch meine eine Liste auf Twitter,
ja weil die Leute die da reinschreiben gibt's so woanders noch nicht ein paar
schon aber eben die meisten nicht also lese ich diesen Kanal weil es gibt den
halt sonst nirgendwo was soll ich machen ich kann denen ja nicht vorschreiben
wo sie jetzt morgen zu posten haben.
Damit kommen wir vielleicht auch schon direkt zum nächsten Meldungsding,
was eigentlich dazugehört und das ist sozusagen der Niedergang von Twix.
Ich finde ja den Namen Twix, ich habe lange auch darüber nachgedacht,
wie ich das nennen soll, aber Twix ist genau das Richtige.
Eigentlich ist es die gleiche Scheiße.
Heißt aber jetzt irgendwie anders, aber man kann mit dem Wort halt sowohl den
guten alten Reiderwitz machen, als auch beide Namen in einem erwähnen.
Praktisch, nicht super. Also Twix, was?
Also weißt du, was ich nicht verstehe, Tim?
Warum überhaupt jetzt, also überall schreiben Leute so auf, schrieb sowieso
auf x in Klammern, vormals Twitter.
Also wer das noch nicht mitbekommen hat, das verstehe ich überhaupt nicht.
Warum man, also warum müssen denn jetzt alle, warum muss man den neuen Namen
denn jetzt unbedingt adaptieren?
Nein, das haben viele nicht mitbekommen. Macht dir nichts vor.
Also dieses Schrieb auf Twitter, ich bitte dich, das ist jetzt in den letzten
zehn Jahren so in Fleisch und Blut übergegangen, nach diesem ganzen Trump-Zirkus
und was nicht alles, verstehst du?
Leute nehmen diese Meldungen zur Kenntnis, a Trump hat oder wer auch immer hat
irgendwie auf Twitter geschrieben. Das hast du jetzt irgendwie seit sechs oder acht Jahren.
So wenn du jetzt aber schreibst auf x dann wissen die leute noch nicht mal was
damit gemeint sein genau auf twitter.
Der ist jetzt auf x ich dachte er wäre auf split.
Aber der ist auf also warum schreibt man nicht einfach weiter twitter.
Weil es ja nicht mehr so heißt.
Und meinst du, wenn man das jetzt trotzdem so nennt, dann verstehen die Leute
nicht mehr, wovon die Rede ist?
Klar, die Leute verstehen ja so schon nicht, wovon die Rede ist. Also Twix.
Twix ist geil. Twix ist so, da ist alles drin, was man wissen muss.
Ja, Rainer heißt jetzt Twix irgendwie und da ist Twitter drin und X und Twix.
Außerdem nennt man es dann nicht so wie Elon Musk möchte, dass man es nennt,
aber man nennt es auch nicht mehr so, wie es nicht mehr heißt.
Also es ist beides drin. Ich finde es super. Ich liebe das. Twix.
Aber das jetzt besser?
Ja, weil es war natürlich nix mit Twix, wie man jetzt auch merkt.
Ein paar Sachen hat sich schon geändert.
Die Einnahmenseite hat sich ein bisschen geändert.
Twitter ist jetzt weniger wert als die Schulden, die es hat.
Super Schlagzeile von Markus, ganz groß.
So und genau, Markus hat aber auch geschrieben warum Blue Sky gerade durch die
Decke geht und was Mastodon daraus lernen kann. habe ich...
Tja ich weiß es nicht genau, also was sagt er ja, also klar Netzkulturen clashen
irgendwie, dann Benutzbarkeit, irgendwie das sieht wieder aus wie Twitter,
ich aber irgendwie also.
Okay, vielleicht wer von euch jetzt auch überhaupt keine Ahnung hat genau was Blue Sky ist,
also Blue Sky war ja mal so ein Projekt von eben genau diesem vorhin schon erwähnten Jack Dorsey,
der nämlich tatsächlich vor einiger Zeit, ich glaube Logbuch Netzpolitik berichtete
auch, mal so die Vision rausgehauen hat, so die Zukunft von Twitter sollte eigentlich dezentral sein.
Da steckt dann vielleicht so ein bisschen sein libertäres Gen drin und was weiß ich,
was er sich dabei wirklich gedacht hat, aber ich glaube diese Leute,
die meandern aber auch wirklich von heute hier morgen da, so oder so,
die Vision war draußen und es gab dann auch ein Team von Leuten,
die dann tatsächlich an so einem Protokoll gearbeitet haben.
Das sogenannte Ad-Protokoll, was jetzt irgendwie implementiert wird und wo es
halt jetzt auch diese eine App gibt.
Es gibt glaube ich schon ein paar andere Apps, aber noch nicht so richtig.
Blue Sky ist halt eigentlich, ich will es jetzt nicht föderiert nennen,
aber es ist aber mal nicht so ganz so zentralisiert, wie das eben Twitter ist,
sondern die Infrastruktur kann so aufgebrochen werden und man kann im Prinzip
auch woanders gehostet werden.
So ähnlich wie das auch Mastodon macht, nur dass sich das nicht in deinem Handel niederschlägt.
Ja also während du halt bei Mastodon irgendwie mehr oder weniger klar sagst
wo dein Zuhause ist, musst du das halt auf Blue Sky so nicht machen.
Derzeit gibt es das nur als App auf IOS und ich glaube auch auf Android oder
und man kommt aber nur an einen Account, wenn man so einen Invite Code kriegt von irgendjemand,
schon auf dem Netz ist, man kriegt da so regelmäßig welche in seinen Account
gespült, also ihr könnt einfach Leute fragen, die schon einen Account haben,
dann kriegt ihr wahrscheinlich auch so einen Invite Code.
Naja und lange Zeit, also ich weiß nicht seit wann verfolge ich das hier jetzt
seit, seit wann läuft das, ein halbes Jahr oder sowas?
Bisschen länger schon, ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau. Auf jeden Fall,
naja ist halt so eben yet another twitter like App quasi so und jetzt seit ein paar Tagen,
also es ging vor zwei Tagen ging das irgendwie total los, ich guckte auch die
ganze Zeit nur auf mein Telefon und war so blim blim blim blim blim.
Wer mir jetzt alles irgendwie gerade wieder gefolgt ist. Kann man abschalten,
ne? Ja ich weiß, es ist mir in dem Moment dann auch aufgefallen,
dass ich vielleicht mal abschalten sollte. Vorher habe ich das irgendwie alle
zwei Tage bekommen, da hat mich das nicht groß interessiert.
So aber dann macht es auf einmal klimmklimm und da dachte ich mir so okay was
ist denn jetzt passiert?
Naja stellt sich raus, dass wohl jetzt gerade so eine, es wieder so eine Kulmination
gab und so eine größere Polit- und Journalisten-Bubble auf Blue Sky marschiert
ist und mit Pocken und Trompeten ihre Twitter-Accounts eingestellt hat.
Und da ist halt genau dieser Effekt wieder passiert, wo sozusagen so ein paar
Meinungsführer die Seiten gewechselt haben und dementsprechend folgt die Community auch nach.
Ob das jetzt Bestand hat, keine Ahnung. Genau diesen Effekt hatten wir ja auch
vor ein paar Monaten bei Macedon,
weil natürlich so die, sagen wir mal Open Source affine Szene sich noch sehr
viel schneller hat da vertreiben lassen durch die Umstände auf Twitter und während
halt die ganzen Medienschaffenden hier noch durchgehalten haben auf Twitter,
weil ja da die Kanäle sind, Könnte es jetzt vielleicht unter Umständen sein,
ich will das überhaupt nicht beschreien oder vorhersagen oder so,
beobachte nur was gerade passiert, es könnte durchaus sein,
dass sozusagen so ein Medienkonglomeration sich auf einmal dort findet und sich
irgendwie drauf einigt,
dass wir jetzt den Scheiß da posten, kann sein, muss nicht passieren und ja
und dann wird sich zeigen was das für Auswirkungen hat.
Und man kann übrigens doch auf die linken, auf die Accounts.
Ich hatte das auch noch in die Shownotes eingepostet, guck mal in die letzten
Shownotes von der letzten Sendung, da hab ich das am Ende noch reingebaut.
Du kannst ja mal linken dann auf meinen Account, da brauch ich noch Follower.
Ja, hast du einen ja. Gut.
Okay, aber also, mehr geht jetzt also nicht. Also wir haben einen Account und ja.
Ja ich hab da nur meinen Platzhalter, Tim Pritlaff und Metaebene,
das ist immer das erste was ich bei so halbwegs relevanten Diensten erstmal
sichere und ob ich dann da wirklich groß ins Posten komme, das entscheidet sich
dann eigentlich erst später, man muss erstmal gucken wie sich das automatisieren lässt und so weiter.
Nach einiger Zeit kommen ja diese Dienste, die dann RSS-Feeds da abwerfen und so.
Gibt's wahrscheinlich auch alles schon, hab ich bloß noch nicht näher geschaut.
Und das ist natürlich auch so eine Sache, warum ich auch anfangs selbst so gezögert habe,
von Twitter Richtung Mastodon zu marschieren, ist halt, ich möchte selbst eigentlich
immer nur wirklich auf Netzwerken präsent sein,
wo ich auch wirklich präsent bin, also wo ich auch wirklich aktiv mitlese, reagiere etc.
Deswegen mache ich zum Beispiel nicht so Cross-Posting-Kram,
was andere immer gemacht haben, so bei anderen Sachen.
Ja, wenn ich hier da was poste auf Twitter, dann hau ich das halt einfach noch
auf allen Netzwerken raus,
bloß dann krieg ich auf diesen anderen Netzwerken, auf denen ich gar nicht präsent
bin, nur einen Account habe, irgendwelche Replies auf Sachen,
die eigentlich für einen ganz anderen Kanal gedacht waren und ich finde man
muss immer schon auf seinen Kanälen immer schon native senden.
Und jetzt bist du gerade in dieser Problematik, nehmen wir Twix mal weg und
lassen wir mal nur Mastodon und Blue Sky,
so zwei Dienste, die sich in ihrem ganzen Erscheinungswesen sehr ähneln,
wo wahrscheinlich wir auch derzeit noch eine sehr marginal sich unterscheidende
Audience haben, so wo postest du jetzt was?
Also erstmal die Frage postest du überhaupt irgendwas und wenn ja wo?
Wo möchtest du dann interagieren? Wo hast du jetzt sozusagen für diesen Kommentar
oder diese Meldung oder diese Verkündung eigentlich die richtige Audience?
Und das muss man für sich natürlich auch selber erstmal rausfinden.
Okay also ich hab mir in der Zeit jetzt mal ein Nostra Account gemacht ich bin
schon ein weiterer als du.
Bei den Crypto Bros?
Ja da kann man, ich hab jetzt hier eine ganze Menge Key Material wenn ich Glück
habe kann ich mich damit nächstes mal wieder anmelden.
Ich mach das jetzt immer, ich will machen mit, ich mach das alles mit,
ich cross-poste das alles voll, bis halt wieder irgendjemand verbietet.
Gab's ja auch schon Keybase irgendwie, das ist ja auch alles,
gab's ja auch alles schon mal.
So, 27.12.
Achso, doch.
Bis 30.12.2023,
findet eine Veranstaltung in Hamburg statt, wenn die Bullen uns die nicht verbieten.
Schweinesystem uns das nicht wieder verbietet.
Oder das Gesundheitsministerium.
Ja, also halte ich für eine sehr geringe Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass eine Veranstaltung verboten wird im Winter. Für äußerst gering.
Und aus diesem Grunde bin ich zaghaft, das jetzt auch öffentlich anzukündigen.
Nein, der Chaos Computer Club hat es jetzt öffentlich angekündigt,
dass im Dezember ein Chaos Communication Congress stattfinden soll.
Ja und zwar in Hamburg im Chaos Communication Center, im Congress Center Hamburg.
Hat er es schon angekündigt, also noch hat er es also nicht,
also während wir hier reden hat er es noch nicht.
Ich wollte jetzt an dieser Stelle so tun als wäre das schon passiert.
Aber du wirst ja sicher sein, dass es dann geschehen sein wird.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es so sein wird, weil ich weiß ja nicht,
wie schnell du die Sendung veröffentlichst,
aber ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass es irgendwann einmal einen Zeitpunkt geben
wird, in dieser Realität, in der man diese Sendung hört und die Aussage der
Chaos Computer Club hat es angekündigt, wahr sein wird.
Okay, also wir sagen einfach, es wird wahr sein.
Es wird wahr gewesen sein.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt als wir es gesagt haben auch wenn es eigentlich noch nicht so weit war.
Ich hab da einfach quasi aus der Vergangenheit in die Zukunft gesprochen.
Okay super also es wird ein Kongress geben und zwar in Hamburg ist das nicht
toll mit anderen Worten der Kongress kehrt zurück an den vorletzten Veranstaltungsort.
Es wird nicht weitergehen in Leipzig das ist insofern keine wirkliche Nachricht
weil das ja eigentlich letztes Jahr schon so angekündigt worden ist.
Das war angekündigt, genau. Und letztes Jahr stand auch extra nicht dabei,
wann, in welchem Jahr das Stadtschutz soll. Nein? Nein.
Alright. Bei uns oder beim Klub?
Die Frage verstehe ich jetzt nicht.
Na ja, also haben wir nicht das Jahr genannt oder?
Also in dem Fall beide Male ich, weil ich auch den Blogpost letztes Jahr geschrieben
habe und da haben wir angekündigt,
dass der Chaos Communication Kongress in Hamburg stattfindet und da stand kein Ja dabei.
Das stimmt.
Aber Einreichung bis November 22 wird schon gefragt. Es gab schon so den Hint dazu.
Alright gut also Kongress dieses Jahr, es gibt wieder ein Kongress mal gucken
ob wir noch wissen wie das geht, weil keine Ahnung wann war jetzt der letzte?
Weiß man auch schon nicht mehr.
2019. Also das ist nicht so schwer, weil 2020 die Pandemie losging.
Also das kann man ja wohl merken.
Ja, hab ich jetzt so dahin gesagt. 2019, aber wer weiß wie lange das her ist.
Also, vier Jahre. Vier Jahre.
Ne, es ist dreimal ausgefallen.
Also 2020 ist ein Jahr, 2021 sind zwei Jahre, 2022 sind drei Jahre,
aber trotzdem würde ich sagen wir haben drei Jahre keinen gemacht.
Drei mal keinen gemacht.
Drei Jahre?
Über einen Zeitraum von vier Jahren gab es keinen Kongress, dreimal haben wir ihn ausfallen lassen.
Aber es gibt drei Jahre, in denen wir keinen gemacht haben. Ja,
wie oft? Ja, okay, drei Kalenderjahre, in denen keines stattgefunden hat.
Ja, okay, wie auch immer.
Also, auf jeden Fall findet es statt und wird anders sein,
weil natürlich jetzt der Ort wieder anders ist, auch wenn es der Ort war,
wo wir schon mal waren, aber das CCH ist ja in der Zwischenzeit umgebaut worden.
Was überhaupt der Grund war, dass wir jemals nach Leipzig gegangen sind.
Genau, das war sozusagen der Auslöser, dass diese Sanierungsmaßnahmen oder Umbaumaßnahmen,
muss man ja fast sagen, dann eben konkret wurden.
Was das bedeutet ist, dass quasi das hintere Drittel ist weitgehend unangetastet,
aber alles, was so ein bisschen älter wirkte im vorderen Bereich,
das ist halt teilweise einfach renoviert worden.
Das bezieht sich auf diesen Saal 1, beziehungsweise komplett neu gemacht worden,
der ganze vordere Foyerbereich und der Saal 2.
Und ich hatte ja auch schon mal die Gelegenheit, du warst sicherlich auch vor
Ort, oder warst du, was war das?
Ich war schon mal im CCH, ja, aber ich war auch schon mal beim Kongress.
Oder meinst du die neue Sache?
Nee, ich meine seit dem Umbau.
Nee, aber ich bin auch gerade völlig irritiert, dass du sagst,
der Saal 1 wäre umgebaut worden. Nach meinem Verständnis wurde der komplett weggetrümmert.
Nein, nein, Saal 1 ist in alter Fasson, sieht aber noch schicker aus als früher.
Also der ist ja quasi erhalten geblieben, aber ist komplett modernisiert worden,
neue Sitze, neue Elektrik, aber der Saal 1 sieht noch so aus wie früher.
Was halt komplett weggefallen ist, ist der Saal 2, im vorderen Teil,
der ist komplett weggenommen worden und durch einen Saal Z ersetzt worden,
der nicht über drei, sondern nur noch über zwei Etagen geht,
aber hoch genug ist und darunter die freigewordenen Bereiche sind jetzt so Multifunktionsbereiche.
Da ist also mehr flexibler Raum. Außerdem gibt es ein großes Foyer.
Ey, bist du wirklich sicher, dass der Saal 1 noch steht?
Ja, ich war drin. Ich hab's gesehen.
Jaja, der ist noch da. Denkmalschutz und so. Der existiert.
Der Saal 2 ist ersetzt worden. Durch den Saal Z. Und dann gibt es halt diese
Multifunktionsbereiche,
es gibt ein großes Eingangsfoyer und über die gesamte Strecke des Gebäudes ist
sozusagen an der Seite nochmal eine leichte Erweiterung rangeflanscht worden,
damit man eben auch an allen Sälen vorbeigehen kann, das ermöglicht dem CCH
zum Beispiel Veranstaltungen im Saal 1 durchzuführen, die komplett abgetrennt
sind von allen anderen und so.
Also man kann jetzt sozusagen in den einzelnen Segmenten Sub-Veranstaltungen
machen ohne andere Veranstaltungen damit zu beeinflussen, was so vorher nicht vorgesehen war.
Das ist ja so ein typisches Element gewesen der Konferenzorte der 70er Jahre,
auch hier das ICC in Berlin ist ja in diesem Design entstanden,
so ein riesiger Ort, wo dann halt so die Aktionärsversammlung von Mercedes-Benz
stattfindet und überhaupt die ganze Zeit ist da immer nur so ein großes Ding.
Und heutzutage hat sich natürlich der ganze Veranstaltungsmarkt hin zu vielen kleinen Variablen,
Veranstaltungen entwickelt, die gleichzeitig stattfinden wollen,
die gleichzeitig bespielt werden und das war halt in dem CCH so nicht mehr ohne weiteres machbar.
Im hinteren Bereich schon, aber eben vorne nicht. Und deswegen ist es jetzt
so, für uns bedeutet das, es ist etwas mehr Platz da, es ist etwas mehr Flexibilität auch im Platz.
Sieht insgesamt sehr schick aus, ich finde es ist gut geworden,
aber selbstverständlich weniger Fläche als in Leipzig.
Also diese, ist deutlich, ja also ich meine das ist ja nicht anders zu machen
und natürlich wird es vor allem und das sehe ich auch so ein bisschen mit einem weinenden Auge,
wird es eben der Ausbreitungsfähigkeit dieser Assemblies Assemblies, ja also ...
Eine Grenze setzen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau wie die Pläne sind,
aber an anderen Stellen wird Raum geschaffen werden, nur wird es natürlich nicht so ausgedehnt sein.
Das ist natürlich auch ein Vorteil, weil Leipzig war zu groß.
Es war einfach viel, die Wege waren zu weit.
Es war irgendwie eine interessante Phase fand ich.
Es hat dem Kongress nochmal so ein unerwartetes Wachstum ermöglicht und konnte
etwas experimentieren mit sich selbst. Ich finde der Kongress war am Ende mehr
so eine Art Indoor Camp geworden.
Und was ich ganz wertfrei sage, ich fand das einfach interessant,
nur der Aufwand, diese Veranstaltung auch zu stemmen aus der Community heraus,
der war halt auch wirklich hoch.
Also es war wirklich krass, was da logistisch geleistet werden musste,
um diese Veranstaltung wirklich zu bespielen.
Und von daher sind, glaube ich, viele auch sehr glücklich darüber,
dass man im CCH trotz einer hohen Teilnehmerzahl kürzere Wege hat.
Also, dass einfach durch die Etagen und so weiter, da fährt man halt mit dem
Fahrschuh mal hoch und muss nicht irgendwie 300, 400, 500 Meter laufen,
um irgendwo zu sein. Und das kann sich auch positiv auswirken.
Genau, man kann jetzt, also in Leipzig gab es im Prinzip zwei Ebenen,
ja, die Glaswurst, die war ja etwas niedriger als die anderen Hallen,
aber de facto dadurch, dass die Glaswurst ja quasi auch einfach nur unterschiedliche
Höhe war, war im Prinzip das ganze topologisch nur eine Fläche.
Ich habe ganz wenige Stellen, an denen etwas übereinander vertikal war.
Diesen Hauptraum da, das Kongresscenter Leipzig quasi, wo wir aber hauptsächlich
irgendwelche internen Räume hatten.
Das ist beim CCH natürlich anders. Das ist auf mehreren Ebenen,
also die Fläche ist jetzt vertikal angeordnet, Was dank der Rolltreppe und der Erfindung.
Des Aufzugs insgesamt den Schrittezähler auf eurer Apple Watch oder eurem Open
Source Device am Handgelenk nicht so stark beansprucht.
Ihr könnt eure Tretroller verkaufen.
Das hätte ich nicht gesagt, weil ich meine so schnell verkaufen würde.
Ja, du hast recht. Also ich muss tatsächlich sagen, ich bin die ganze Zeit unter
der, also ich habe jetzt mehrere Jahre unter der festen Überzeugung gelebt,
dass der Saal 1 weggedrümmert wird und nicht der Saal 2.
Insofern noch eine gute Nachricht.
Genau und das ist, und ich muss auch sagen, als ich bei der Begehung letztes
Jahr da war und das das erste Mal gesehen habe,
wie das sozusagen nach dem Umbau aussah, das Gefühl, was man bekommen hat,
als man in diesen Saal reingegangen ist.
Das hast du mir damals auf der Republika erzählt.
Also das war für mich einfach so, okay wow, das ist der Ort,
wo so ein Kongress, wo dieser Kongress leben kann, weil das ist das Ding,
was ich in Leipzig nicht mehr hatte.
Also das war einfach, diese Hallen, es war alles super, wir haben uns alle viel
Mühe gegeben, das irgendwie zu bespielen und so weiter, aber es ist nicht das gleiche.
Und insofern freue ich mich sehr darauf, dass dort eine Eröffnungsveranstaltung stattfindet,
die dann vielleicht auch dem Charakter der Veranstaltung sehr gerecht wird und
dann könnte das ganz toll werden. Mh. Ja.
Man kann, also damit sind jetzt die Hotelpreise in Hamburg zu der Jahreszeit eh schon erledigt.
War schon vor zwei drei Monaten im Eimer.
Sehr bald werden dann also jetzt die Infos zum Vorverkauf folgen,
natürlich zum CFP ja auch da, zum CFP kann ich jetzt schon mal sagen,
ihr könnt euch alle ausmachen, dass das jetzt gerade mal noch,
irgendwie zwei Monatchen sind bis zu der Veranstaltung.
Das heißt, ihr könnt euch jetzt schon mal Gedanken machen über das,
was ihr dort potenziell einreichen möchtet an Inhalten, weil es nicht lange
dauern wird, bis dieser CFP eröffnet und vor allem bis er wieder schließt und
eine Auswahl stattfindet.
Und ja, es wird alles auch, also Vorverkauf und Voucher-Phase für die Engel,
die ja geholfen haben und so, das wird alles sehr viel kürzer.
Ja, weil das eben, das ist so, weil es bald ist. Muss so sein.
Ja, schön. Ja, könnt ihr
euch überlegen ob er sozusagen über weihnachten die
zeit Nicht wieder so wie in
den letzten jahren einfach mit mondänen urlaub füllt sondern
einfach mal wieder auf eine konferenz geht Du wolltest
natürlich sagen dass alle in rc3 streams geguckt haben tim Im urlaub Ja klar
im urlaub Möchtest du noch was zum cch sagen ich würde also ich finde schon
mal super dass in sal 1 abstellen dass wir wirklich jahrelang war ich Ich bin
fest davon überzeugt, dass sie den wegtrümmern.
Ein Wunder! Halleluja! Ich könnte noch viel dazu sagen, aber ich glaube,
jetzt liegt es mehr zur Sache. Okay.
So, dann wollen wir noch mal ein bisschen über die Chat-Kontrolle sprechen.
Da wird ja jetzt über die Verflechtungen und die Hintergrundpläne immer mehr bekannt.
Also immer ekeligere Details.
Das ist ja ein sehr relativ umfangreiches Ding. Wir haben uns ja immer viel
mit der Erkennung auseinandergesetzt,
dass da künstliche Intelligenzsysteme oder so unziemlichen Inhalt erkennen sollen.
Und worüber wir in letzter Zeit gar nicht mehr so viel gesprochen haben,
weil wir viel über technische Details gesprochen haben, ist,
konsequent soll ja eine Meldung an Europol sein, an ein EU-Zentrum,
bei dem dann diese ganzen Meldungen eingehen.
Da soll eine Datenbank mit Indikatoren für sexuellen Kindesmissbrauch im Internet
eingerichtet werden, die soll gepflegt und betrieben werden Und die Anbieter
müssen die dann nutzen, um ihren Aufdeckungspflichten nachzukommen.
Das bedeutet, die müssen das da drin melden und die Verdachtsmeldungen der Anbieter entgegennehmen.
Und dann werden sie dort geprüft und dann
an Europol und die nationalen Strafverfolgungsbehörden weitergeleitet.
Geprüft heißt, guckt noch mal ein Mensch drauf. Das heißt,
eure false positives, wo dann eine KI sagt,
das ist aber jetzt hier dokumentierter Kindesmissbrauch, das schicken wir jetzt,
das leiten wir jetzt aus, dann guckt erst mal jemand drauf, um vielleicht festzustellen,
dass es das nicht wäre, ja?
Also auch eine super Vorstellung für eure konsensuell ausgetauschten Bildchen
unter erwachsenen Menschen, die einfach echt jung geblieben sind.
Dann sagt Europol, also gibt es ein Gesprächsprotokoll, mal wieder bei Netzpolitik.org
geleakt, sagt Europol, ja es gibt ja auch andere Kriminalitätsbereiche,
die von der Aufdeckung profitiert würden,
schreibt die doch am besten mal direkt mit ins Gesetz und sorgt mal bitte dafür,
dass wir KI-Instrumente für Ermittlungen nutzen dürfen und zum Beispiel auch
für Abhörmaßnahmen einsetzen können, weil dann müssen wir den ganzen Scheiß
nicht mehr selber lesen.
Also Europol auf jeden Fall volles Fund auf dem AI-Trip und sagen,
ja sie würden auch gerne noch von den Wechselwirkungen zwischen dem Aufgabenbereich
des künftigen EU-Zentrums und Europol profitieren.
Wir müssen alle relevanten Informationen erhalten,
um die EU und ihre BürgerInnen, liebe Europol, vor schwerer und organisierter
Kriminalität, einschließlich natürlich auch sexuellem Missbrauch von Kindern zu schützen.
Die stehen da jetzt schon in den Startlöchern. Ja man sagt ja,
alles wird wahr. Du sagst irgendwie so, pass auf, wenn ihr das einmal macht,
dann kommen die mit ihren Begehrlichkeiten.
Da sitzt Europol jetzt schon bereit und möchte all das haben.
Glücklicherweise weiterhin stellt sich dar, dass die Bundesregierung alles verhindern
möchte, was private verschlüsselte Kommunikation durchleuchtet.
Explizit auch das Client-Side-Scanning.
Darin sind sich Buschmann, also
der Justizminister Marco Buschmann und Innenministerin Nancy Faeser einig.
Und das ist gut, weil Nancy Faeser ja lange offen war zum Bruch des Koalitionsvertrages.
Sie sich da inzwischen dann doch einer besseren hat belehren lassen, ja.
Außerdem haben wir in der letzten Sendung ja sehr enttäuscht auch darüber gesprochen
oder sehr desillusioniert.
Was kann man denn sagen? Es ist weder Desillusion, es ist auch keine Enttäuschung,
weil man es auch die ganze Zeit so erwartet hat. Ähm...
Angewidert, könnten wir sagen, angewidert von den Lobby-Verpflechtungen rund
um Ilvia Eva Johansson gesprochen.
Also Eva Johansson, die EU-Kommissarin, die das Ganze vorantreibt.
Die ja dann, die hat ein Strongly Worded Letter bekommen aus dem Liebe-Ausschuss,
also dem Committee on Civil Liberties, Justice and Home Affairs,
Vom Chairman dieses Committees, das ist der Juan Fernando Lopez Aguiar,
auch über den haben wir gesprochen.
Der ist nämlich, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, Spanier.
Also ich würde jetzt, also nennt mich von Vorurteilen belastet,
aber ich unterstelle dem Mann, dass er Spanier ist.
Lass mich kurz gucken.
Jetzt wird's spannend.
Ja, genau. Er ist von der Partido Socialista Obrero Español und damit mitgibt
der progressiven Allianz der Sozialdemokraten im Europäischen Parlament.
Und der hat dann, also Ilva Johansson, geschrieben und sagte,
ja, also hier pass mal auf, wir gesehen.
Ich würde gerne meine Sorge über kürzlich veröffentlichte Berichte zum Ausdruck bringen,
dass es hier Interessenkonflikte gibt mit Bezug auf die Regulierung,
die du hier anstrebst und Und deine Arbeitsbeziehungen zwischen der Europäischen
Kommission und den Tech-Companies, davon profitieren, einem Geflecht aus.
Stiftungen, PR-Agenturen und Tech-Companies, darunter THORN,
die We Protect Global Alliance.
Und dass es hier den Eindruck von undue influence, also unangemessenem Einfluss
auf die Erstellung dieses Proposals gibt.
Insbesondere scheint es so zu sein, dass die Gruppen hier mit ökonomischem Interesse
im Hintergrund mitgewirkt haben.
Wir würden freundlich darum bitten, ein paar Erklärungen und Klarstellungen
zu diesen Anschuldigungen zu erhalten.
Wir denken, dass Ihre Kooperation und eine zügige Reaktion dem Vertrauen und
der Transparenz dienen würde,
welches Werte sind, die im Herzen der Europäischen Union sind.
Das würde ich jetzt als strongly worded letter bezeichnen.
Muss ich auch wirklich mal sagen.
Also wenn das jetzt nicht mit Chat-GPT gemacht wurde, dann bewundere ich teilweise so diese,
wie man so, mit so freundlichen Worten,
dann doch sehr schwere Vorwürfe beschreiben kann und da hätte ich natürlich,
da rechnet man natürlich damit, dass Eva Johansson jetzt Aufklärung verschafft
und sich gegen diese Vorwürfe zuwehrsetzt, Aufklärung betreibt.
Und sagt so pass auf so und so sieht das hier aus und ich kann das alles erklären.
Hier wurde irgendwas in den falschen Kontext gerückt. Mein Mitarbeiter,
der arbeitet gar nicht bei dieser, der ist gar nicht Mitglied in dieser Lobbyorganisation.
Ich habe auch keine Werbevideos von Lobbyorganisationen mitgemacht und verbreitet
oder deren PR-Aktionen mit Pressefotos unterstützt.
Ich habe auch nicht E-Mails an die geschrieben und gesagt, jetzt hoffe ich,
dass ihr das Proposal, was wir gemeinsam geschrieben haben, so unterstützt,
dass wir es auch über die Bühne kriegen.
Könnte das könnte sie jetzt irgendwie erklären aber sie entscheidet sich für
den Hubsi-Style. Kennst du Hubsi-Style?
Ne. Was ist der Hubsi-Style?
Du bist echt angekotzt von Deutschland. Kann ich total verstehen.
Eiwanger. Der Eiwanger ist der Hubsi.
Achso.
Die hat das Thema jetzt einfach mal geeiwangert mit zweieinhalb DIN A4 Seiten
mit großem Zeilenabstand.
Und sagt irgendwie, ja hier danke für ihren Brief und die Gelegenheit, den zu kommentieren.
Dann fasst sie erst mal zusammen, was da steht und dann sagt sie irgendwie so,
dass diese Medienartikel falsch wären,
sie hätte immerhin eine ganze Menge NGOs getroffen,
übrigens Edry hat dreimal angefragt und wurde dreimal abgewiesen und noch nicht einmal angehört,
obwohl man eigentlich erwartet hätte, dass sie ja wenigstens im Rahmen der Feindbeobachtung
mal einmal mit denen spricht, hat sie auch nicht gemacht.
Ja, und sind dann so Sätze drin wie, verteidigt nochmal your proposal,
the answer to the question who benefits from my proposal is children.
And who benefits from its rejection, abusers who can continue their crimes undetected
and possibly big tech companies and messaging services who do not want to be
regulated. Voll nach vorne, ja.
Diese Newsreports seem to be designed to give the impression of wrongdoing,
let me assure you there is none. Ende. Das ist also, das ist, äh, was?
Das klingt sehr überzeugend, würde ich sagen.
Sie verteidigt einfach, also es ist, du, du, du, du, du, du,
äh, das können die doch nicht durchgehen lassen, ne?
Sie schreibt einfach nochmal, also auf der ersten Seite fasst sie zusammen,
was ihr gefragt, was sie gefragt wurde,
ja, dann große Medienschelte, ja,
der Artikel, auf den sie sich beziehen,
der in verschiedenen Versionen von unterschiedlichen Medien veröffentlicht wurde,
was ja erstmal üblicherweise ein positives Signal ist,
ja, wir haben ja letzte Woche darüber gesprochen, dass das eben unterschiedliche
internationale Medien sind,
unter anderem, ich glaube, wir haben dann viel aus der Zeit zitiert, ist ein Versuch,
eine, den ganz normalen, die ganz normale konsultative Arbeit der Kommission
in Misscredit zu bringen.
Also klassische politische Verteidigungsarbeit,
ich hab nichts wirklich klarzustellen, weil die Fakten sind nicht auf meiner
Seite, sondern nur wenn ihr gegen mich seid, dann seid ihr für das Böse und
wie könnt ihr nur, das klingt jetzt nicht besonders überzeugend, wenn du mich fragst.
Let the text of the proposal speak for itself, ne?
Also, alter, die geht da überhaupt nicht drauf ein. Also, das ist ein,
was da wirklich steht ist, hier gibt es schwerwiegende Vorwürfe, verhalte dich dazu.
Und ihre Antwort ist, mein Proposal ist gut und die Medien,
internationale Medien von gutem Läumund, Versuchen hier, und jetzt ist natürlich
auch das Wichtige, sie sagt spezifisch nicht, mich in Misskredit zu bringen,
sondern die gesamte Kommission.
Das ist ein Angriff auf die Kinder und die Kommission und am besten noch die Demokratie.
Ja, unglaublich, ja und dann und wieder. Also der letzte Satz,
es ist Deshalb unsere geteilte Verantwortung als Politiker,
diese Balance sicherzustellen und alles zu tun,
was wir können, um allen Kindern eine Zukunft frei von sexuellem Missbrauch
und seinen schrecklichen lebenslangen Konsequenzen zu bereiten.
Das war nicht Thema der Anfrage. Es ist einfach gar nicht die Frage gewesen.
Der Liebeausschuss hat sie ja nicht zum Inhalt ihres Proposals gefragt.
Er hat sie gefragt, erklär mal bitte, mit was für einem Haufen du das da machst?
Übrigens, achso, habe ich gerade ganz vergessen zu erzählen, die beiden,
die da jetzt, also die Europol-Leute, es gibt ehemalige Mitarbeiter der Europol,
die jetzt bei diesem Lobby-Netzwerk aktiv sind, ne?
Und das Lobby-Netzwerk ist auch in den USA aktiv, da ist es die Heat Initiative,
die haben bei der Vorstellung der neuen iPhones im September eine ganzseitige
Anzeige in der New York Times geschaltet,
Eine ganz ecktige Anzeige in der New York Times, als ich letztes Mal eine geschaltet
habe, war ein paar hunderttausend Euro, ne?
Und da haben ein Flugzeug gemietet, mit dem sie irgendwie über die Apple-Zentrale geflogen sind,
das war wahrscheinlich billiger, und auf dem Banner stand,
Dear Apple, detect child sexual abuse in iCloud, ja, ähm, also,
krass, es ist wirklich ekelig.
Es ist richtig, richtig übel. Und das ist, das ist ein,
das ist ein Verfall politischer Kultur,
das ist Schrupalla-Style, ja, das ist Trump-Style, Das sind Angriffe auf das,
was wir als Demokratie versuchen, aufrechtzuerhalten und zu verteidigen.
Dass wir mit Fakten basiert in einem Austausch,
in dem man auch Rechenschaft schuldig ist und durch die Medien kontrolliert
wird, die den ganzen Tag nur Wadenbeißer sind. Ja, das ist deren Job.
Aber nein, denen unterstellt man jetzt unlautere Motive, wenn man sich,
wenn man, also das ist...
Du bist entsetzt, sag es doch einfach.
Ich bin entsetzt, ja entsetzt ist das, ja entsetzt.
Ja, empört auch ein bisschen.
Ja, ein bisschen, aber weißt du Tim, ich will jetzt auch nicht,
dass sich hier den ganzen Tag Leute über Politik aufregen, so wie du,
nicht dass dir das zu viel wird.
Nee, einfach nicht mit Beschäftigenden geht das.
Wir machen den Podcast jetzt nicht mehr, wir regen uns nur auf.
Ich möchte, dass die Welt besser wird, je tiefer wir da in den Keller der Wurstfabrik laufen.
Umso mehr findest du heraus, Chat-Kontrolle ist People.
Titel, Vorschlag, Notiergeräusch.
Es ist wirklich schrecklich. Und du musst dir überlegen, auf der anderen Seite hast du Menschen,
die ernsthaft, die anständig sind und ernsthafte inhaltliche Überzeugungsarbeit leisten,
die seit Jahren, also nehmen wir mal Patrick Breyer, nehmen wir die ganzen Organisationen,
die sich bei Edry zusammenschließen, nehmen wir Leute aus dem CCC,
nehmen wir Leute bei Netzpolitik.org.
Nehmen wir alle, alle möglichen NGOs, die sich damit auseinandersetzen.
Und die werden noch nicht einmal angehört.
Und dann soll am Ende jemand sagen, Demokratie echt überlegenes System.
Also in dem Prozess hat er vertraut.
Ja, Pluralismus, wohin man schaut. Ja, also wenn man überall hinschauen würde.
Ja, genau.
So sieht es aus. Also die Kommissarin kann nicht so richtig erklären,
warum sie so viel mit der Lobby rumhuscht, sich mit den anderen Vertretern der
Gesellschaft nicht schützen möchte.
Und beschimpft einfach mal alle und sagt einfach, ja lest doch selbst, was da steht.
Dann seht ihr, ich bin hier die Heldin und die Befreierin der Kinder und alle
Kinder haben keine Zukunft, wenn nicht mein Gesetz durchkommt,
ohne dass ich dafür kritisiert werde.
Ignorance is strength. Kann ich dazu nur sagen. So, nächstes Thema.
Und zwar gibt es, also ja, sozialen Netzwerk, Twix, wie auch immer.
Ich nenne es jetzt einfach Twitter.
Auf Twitter gab es, ich habe einen, einer meiner absoluten Lieblings-Tweets
hat jetzt noch stattgefunden.
Im Niedergang, ne, kommt da ja dann immer nochmal so ein kleines Feuerwerk raus.
Und zwar gab es offenbar eine ZDF-Magazin-Royalsendung über Nazi-Chatgruppen bei der Polizei, ne?
Und von denen gibt es ja, also ich weiß nicht, das ist jetzt so eine hohe dreistellige.
Anzahl Einzelfälle, die bisher berichtet wurden, ne?
Und das deutet ja dann eben unter Umständen darauf hin, dass man ein systematisches Problem hat,
über das sich viele Leute Gedanken machen, unter anderem zum Beispiel schon
sehr lange und sehr reflektiert und gut Oliver von Dobrowolski,
Polizeihauptkommissar, ich glaube hier in Berlin, Antifaschist,
bezeichnet sich als Antifaschist und Gründer und Sprecher von Better Police,
einer Organisation, die sich eben zum Ziel gesetzt hat, ja, die Polizei zu verbessern.
Und zwar zu verbessern, in dem, ja, sie sich mehr Vertrauen aus der Gesellschaft wiederverdient.
Weniger Gewalt, weniger Rassismus, die schwarzen Schafe aussortieren.
Das hat dem Oliver von Dobrowolski natürlich auch dazu geführt,
dass er selber von vielen in der Polizei als schwarzes Schaf wahrgenommen wird.
Dem stellt er sich natürlich äußerst entschieden entgegen und dem möchte ich
auch absolut widersprechen,
weil das jemand ist, der die Bedeutung der Institution, der Polizei in einer
Gesellschaft würdigt und diesen Ruf reinhalten möchte, weil er die Bedeutung
der Polizei für ein Staatswesen erkannt hat und deswegen schützen möchte.
Man könnte sagen, der Mann liebt die Polizei, deswegen möchte er natürlich auch
darauf hinwirken, dass sie die beste Polizei ist, die wir haben können.
Der kommentiert dann diese Sendung von ZDF-Magazin, die ich nicht geschaut habe.
Wenn die Einzelfallparade AKA
zu 9S das Problem mit Nazis in der deutschen Polizei solcher Ausmaße hat,
dass nicht mal eine einzige Ausgabe des ZDF-Magazin dafür reicht,
meine Fresse, kommentiert er. Daraufhin antwortet ihm irgendein Twitter-Vogel.
Warte mal ab, bis du die Polizei mal selber brauchst und meld dich danach nochmal.
Antwort Oliver von Dobrowolski, ich bin die Polizei, Digga.
Der Tweet hat inzwischen, ich glaube so siebeneinhalbtausend Likes,
weil es natürlich einfach so ein klassischer Twitter versenkt,
irgendein, irgend so ein Durchkommentierer, der den ganzen Tag im Internet hetzt,
dieser Typ, der da kommentiert, äußert auch den ganzen Tag nicht,
sich nicht zu anderen Themen als, ne, zum, wer alles auf die Fresse kriegen sollte, so ungefähr.
Das war seit langer Zeit einer meiner Lieblings-Tweets, laut gelacht,
gerne geklickt und deswegen habe ich den jetzt als Einstieg gewürdigt in das
Thema, nämlich das Projekt MachMeldung.
Eine Infoseite von der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte und der Alfred-Landeker-Stiftung, die.
Unter mach-meldung.org über den Schutz von Hinweisgeberinnen bei der Polizei
aufklären und damit zu einer besseren Fehlerkultur bei der Polizei beitragen
und so die Hinweisgeberinnen,
den Rechtsstaat und die Demokratie stärken.
Da erklären sie die Umsetzung des neuen Hinweisgeber-Schutzgesetzes,
da komme ich gleich nochmal drauf, zurück und arbeiten außerdem auch auf die
Schließung bestehender Regelungs- und Schutzlücken hin, darauf komme ich gleich zurück.
Da kann man sich also über die Rechte als Whistleblowerin informieren.
Da werden Schulungen angeboten zum Thema Hinweisgabe im Polizeidienst.
Wird durch eine Umfrage eine Studie angefertigt auf Basis von Interviews mit Polizistinnen,
um also quasi dieses Core-Geist zu brechen, was ja dazu führt,
dass die Scherwarzen Schafe in unserer Polizei geschützt werden.
Und damit der Demokratie schaden können. Und zwar noch sehr viel mehr,
als sie es als Individuen könnten. Das finde ich ein sehr gutes Projekt,
was ich hier gerne erwähnen möchte.
Man kann da also nicht selber melden, aber man kann dann zum Beispiel sagen,
ich bin jetzt irgendwie Berliner Polizist und ich möchte gerne eine Meldung machen.
Und dann wird man darüber aufgeklärt, welche, wie jetzt die Rechte sind und
Bedingungen und wird dann in diesem Fall zur...
Ich glaube, in Berlin landet man dann auf so einer Seite beim Justizministerium,
wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Also man landet da auf jeden Fall an der richtigen Stelle, wo dann natürlich
auch steht, wenn du eine falsche Aussage machst, strafrechtliche Konsequenzen und so weiter.
Immerhin wird das jetzt mal überhaupt motiviert, dass man Fehlverhalten von
Polizistinnen zur Meldung bringen kann.
Und dafür braucht man natürlich Schutz.
Eine Frage, wendet sich das jetzt primär an Polizisten?
Ja, das wendet sich spezifisch an Polizistinnen und Polizisten.
Und deswegen habe ich gerade die ganze Zeit gesagt, ich komme auf das Hinweisgeber-Schutz-Gesetz,
weil ich gerade die Kritik daran noch mit einbringen möchte.
Denn das ist also so, es gibt dieses Hinweisgeber-Schutz-Gesetz,
also im Prinzip kannst du dir sagen, das ist ein Whistleblower-Schutz-Gesetz
oder ein Whistleblower-Motivations-Gesetz, ja.
Und nochmal, das klingt ja immer erstmal komisch, wenn man jetzt irgendwie sich
Infrastrukturen in Organisationen aufbaut für anonyme Meldung,
ne. Und was weiß ich, Denunziation und was es da alles für uns schöne Begriffe zu gibt.
Aber das ist in solchen, gerade mit Macht versehenen Organisationen eben notwendig,
um die Organisation, auch wenn sie einmal groß und einflussreich genug ist und
ausreichend hohe Hierarchien hat, davor zu schützen, sagen wir mal so.
Sowas wie die katholische Kirche zu werden. Also die hätten sich über ein Hinweisgeber-System
und entsprechende Regeln sicherlich freuen können.
Da wäre sehr viel Leid erspart geblieben und es hätte auch der Organisation geholfen.
Und was passiert, wenn man das nicht hat und damit nicht entsprechend umgeht,
das sieht man eben auch an der katholischen Kirche.
Also ab einer gewissen Größe an Organisationen ist so etwas notwendig,
weil sich sonst eben zu krasse Hierarchien, Einflussgefüge ergeben,
dass Missstände nicht mehr aus sich selbst heraus behoben werden können.
Dann kann so eine Organisation infiziert oder infiltriert werden und dann geht
sie kaputt, wenn man das nicht macht.
Und deswegen, das sind also keine Denunziationsdinge, sondern das ist ein ganz
normaler, notwendiger Selbstheilungsprozess, den man eben unterstützen muss,
dem man Kristallisationspunkte geben muss.
So, jetzt wurde endlich eine Richtlinie von 2019 umgesetzt im Sommer,
das ist das Hinweisgeber-Schutzgesetz und da kritisiert aber jetzt das Whistleblower-Netzwerk,
das ist die Organisation in Deutschland, die sich sehr um.
Solche Fragestellungen bemüht, ja. Und die beschweren sich jetzt über Deutschland
und die Umsetzung, diese sehr späte und nach ihrer Betrachtung nicht ausreichenden Umsetzung.
Und die fand ich jetzt mal ganz interessant, weil sie beschweren sich über fünf
Aspekte, ich zitiere jetzt mal nicht, äh über zwölf, ich zitiere jetzt mal eher so sechs vielleicht.
Weil es sehr interessant ist, weil sie da nämlich diesen Prozess des Whistleblowings
und wie man ihn motivieren kann, ganz gut beleuchten, finde ich.
Wenn Sie also sagen, also, Sache ist ja ...
Potenziell sollen die Missstände ja auch mal offengelegt werden.
Eventuell auch, wenn du es intern nicht geschafft hast, vielleicht auch einfach über die Presse.
Dann sagen sie, ja, das Hinweisgeberschutzgesetz enthält ein Verbot der Offenlegung
unrichtiger Informationen,
das die Schutzvoraussetzungen der Richtlinie, also der EU-Richtlinie,
nicht berücksichtigt und dadurch
wirkt es abschreckend auf potenzielle Whistleblower. Was heißt das?
Du, wenn du etwas offenlegst und da ist irgendwie ein Detail nicht drin richtig,
dann machst du dich quasi, also dann ist das verboten, dann machst du dich im Prinzip straffällig.
Das ist natürlich erstmal abschreckend, weil das heißt, wenn du jetzt irgendwo
etwas offenlegst und da ist ein kleiner Fehler drin oder sonst was,
dass dir da eben Strafen verdrohen, ist natürlich ein Problem.
Und du darfst nach diesem Gesetz selbst dann Verstöße nicht offenlegen,
wenn nur geringe Aussichten bestehen, dass die zuständigen Ermittlungsbehörden
wirksam gegen den Verstoß vorgehen werden.
Also wenn du schon erkennst, dass die internen Kräfte nicht wirken werden,
dann darfst du trotzdem nicht an die Öffentlichkeit gehen.
Was ja hauptsächlich der Grund ist, an die Öffentlichkeit zu gehen,
wenn die internen die Kräfte und die zuständigen Ermittlungsbehörden nicht wirksam
gegen den Verstoß vorgehen werden.
Erinnert mich übrigens hier so an Meldungen von Sicherheitslücken,
wo du nämlich sagst, pass auf, ich werde einfach an die Öffentlichkeit gehen,
ihr könnt ja jetzt was gegen ein Unternehmen oder nicht.
Also die Veröffentlichung ist ja auch ein wichtiges Druckmittel für eine ordentliche
Behebung des Missstandes Druck ausüben zu können.
Und dann gibt es hier die Priorität für interne Meldungen. Du hast nämlich keine
Wahlfreiheit, ob du intern meldest.
Das Hinweisgeberinnen-Schutzgesetz vermittelt den falschen Eindruck,
dass sich Hinweisgeber, die einen Verstoß zuerst intern gemeldet haben,
nur dann an staatliche Stellen wenden dürfen, wenn dem Verstoß intern nicht abgeholfen wurde.
Also es entsteht der Eindruck, wenn du es einmal intern gemeldet hast,
dann darfst du es nicht mehr an staatliche Stellen melden.
Und dann gibt es noch andere Sachen. Was ist mit Schadensersatz?
Kriegst du Schadensersatz?
Also hast du Anspruch auf Ersatz immaterieller Schäden, insbesondere Schmerzensgeld,
zum Beispiel wegen der schweren psychischen Belastung für Hinweisgeber.
Das sagt die Richtlinie, aber
solltest du haben. Diesen Anspruch hat Deutschland dann nicht umgesetzt.
Und unvollständige Wiedergutmachung sonstiger Schäden. Also die Hinweisgeberschutzrichtlinie
sagt, sie verlangt eine vollständige Willgutmachung des erlittenen Schadens
und das Hinweisgeberschutzgesetz hat eine Ausnahmeklausel.
Wenn also gegen das Verbot von Repressalien verstoßen wird, hast du keinen Anspruch
auf Begründung eines Beschäftigungsverhältnisses, eines Berufsausbildungsverhältnisses
und so weiter. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Auch da nicht alles abgedeckt. Ansonsten sagen sie noch, alle juristischen Personen
müssen laut, alle juristischen Personen des öffentlichen Sektors,
ab 50 Mitarbeitern müssen eine Meldestelle einrichten, laut EU-Richtlinie.
Aber in der Umsetzung des Hinweisgeberschutzgesetzes wird hingegen der Staat
ermächtigt, das festzulegen, wer das machen muss und wer nicht.
Also schon mal sehr, also fand ich jetzt im Detail sehr interessant,
weil ich einige davon nicht auf Anhieb einleuchtend fand.
Anführungszeichen etwas schwer zu lesen. Aber wenn man sich überlegt,
dass ja hier, so ein Gesetz machst du ja nur sinnvollerweise,
um die Hürden einer Meldung herunterzusetzen.
Und das hat natürlich auch zur Folge, wenn du Hürden einer Meldung heruntersetzt.
Klar, erst mal, dass mehr kommen.
Natürlich auch verständlich, dass da potenziell Falschmeldungen kommen.
Deswegen muss ja auch eine Stelle einrichten, die vernünftig damit umgeht.
Also, klingt für mich alles erstmal schon ganz sinnvoll, wenngleich ich auch
verstehe, dass man sich natürlich, wenn man so etwas einrichtet,
Sorgen macht, was da so kommt.
Und dass man natürlich auch den Fall einer Falschbeschuldigung mal betrachten muss.
Ja, aber fand ich ganz interessant. Und vor diesem Kontext,
dieses Hinweisgeber-Schutzgesetzes, Das ist eben auch dieses Mach-Meldung zu sehen,
die also jetzt, ja, sagen wir mal, zu dem Gesetz für den Bereich der Polizei,
wo der Eindruck zu korrigieren ist,
ich bin mir sicher, dass Eva Johansson den sofort ausräumen kann,
dass eventuell bei einigen Polizisten, ganz wenige, ganz wenige,
irgendwo ein bisschen der Balken schief im Kopf hängt.
Und ich verdächtige all jene, also umso schöner diese Initiative,
diejenigen Polizisten, die sich, bei denen der Walten nicht schief im Kopf hängt, zu motivieren.
Ja, finde ich filmen war ganz schön. Ist in Ordnung.
Jo. Damit wären wir beim Epilog angekommen oder willst du noch was zu,
ach ne, nein, nein, nein,
Krypto Briefmarken, nein Tim,
nein, warum hast du das denn jetzt hier noch in die Schonung,
ich will doch keine Krypto Briefmarken, Mann ey, ich hab mich gerade gefreut,
dass es in den Whistleblower-Polizei für schwarze Schafen unter den Polizisten
gibt, jetzt gibt es eine NFT-Briefmarke.
Das ist so süß. Ich kann auch nichts dafür, dass die Welt...
Boah, du kannst es doch nicht einfach hier so rein, so heimlich in meine Show-Notes, unsere Show-Notes.
Einfach ohne mir Bescheid...
... Das ist mir einfach gerade vor die Nase gekommen.
Kryptobriefmarke.
Ja. Sie mit KI generierten Bildern vom Brandenburger Tor.
Boah, ist das kacke.
Was ist in die... Ist das kacke. Was ist denn kaputt mit euch?
Was sind Kryptobriefmarken? Die Kryptobriefmarke ist eine Kombination aus einer
echten, selbstklebenden Briefmarke.
Yeah! Und ihrem digitalen abbild in der blockchain welche denn hier ist ein
einzigartiger token ein sogenannter nft non-fungible token zugeordnet mit dem
kauf der krypto briefmarke wird man besitzerin eines kleinen digitalen kunstwerks
unsere erste krypto briefmarke erscheint am 2.
November in einer limitierten auflage von 250.000.
Stück Liebe deutsche post ich habe gerade noch mal nachgeschaut schaut, es ist schon 2023.
Sag mal, haben die den Schuss nicht gehört?
Ich meine der war doch wirklich laut. Knallbumm.
In den USA fahren die gerade diesen Sam Beckman Freed irgendwie in den Knast ein,
der wird jetzt die Tage von der Jury zu 500 Jahren irgendwie verurteilt im Knast
und die ganze Kryptoblase ist irgendwie am poppen.
NFTs, keiner macht damit irgendwie Geld mehr, 95 Prozent der Leute haben irgendwie
ihre Kohle einfach verloren, das ist einfach alles nichts wert,
das war auch vorher schon klar, weil es ist nichts wert.
Es war auch nie was wert, du hast halt viel Geld dafür bezahlt.
Ja und jetzt wollt ihr irgendwie Briefmarken raushauen, die irgendwie alle auch
noch gleich aussehen, aber jede einzelne Briefmarke soll irgendwie ein Kunstwerk
sein und das soll irgendwas wert sein?
Wer... Übrigens zeitgleich erscheint
das Motiv auch als nass klebende Briefmarke, allerdings ohne NFT.
Ha? Wieso dat dann?
Ja das ist dann, also wenn du da dran rumleckst, dann ist das ja nix wert,
ne? Ne das muss schon selbst weg sein.
Aber was mir auffällt, weißt du welchen Hintergrund, welche Farbe die Prüfmark hat?
Karpatschow. Karpatschow.
Karpatschow. Ist so. Zwei Grün oder Blau oder was auch immer.
Oh Gott.
Du, aber weißt du was? Also ich sag mal, ähm...
Ich, ich, also ich hab jetzt, sagen wir mal so...
Wenn ich mir jetzt, ich will mich jetzt nicht weit, ich nehm mich jetzt mal weit aus dem Fenster.
Okay, mach mal das mit.
Der durchschnittliche Briefmarkensammler, ja?
Der wird jetzt vielleicht nicht so immer the latest news am Smartphone verfolgen.
Meinst du?
Und so als Zielgruppe, wenn da irgendeiner sitzt und sagt, ey wem könnten wir
noch NFTs andrehen, finde ich jetzt Briefmarkensammler nicht die dümmste Zielgruppe.
Also nicht die am wenigsten naheliegende Zielgruppe.
Also nachdem jetzt alle anderen schon ordentlich übers Ohr gehauen wurden,
müssen jetzt auch noch die Filialisten auch noch dran glauben,
die der Post seit Jahrhunderten die Treue halten, begeistert sind.
Vor allem Briefwagen sammeln, das sind ja wirklich die besten,
weil die nehmen ja noch nicht mal die Dienstleistung in Anspruch.
Oder verschicken die ja nicht, die kleben die ja, ne selbst.
Ich will eine NFT Briefmarke, ich nehme eine NFT. Ich will die haben.
Ja, was kostet die denn überhaupt? Musst ein Newsletter, musst du jetzt hier irgendwie bestellen.
Die wird ja wohl hoffentlich so viel bekommen, wie da drauf steht.
Am 14. Oktober gibt's die im Shop. Und alle wichtigen Informationen kriegst
du über den Shop Newsletter. Da musst du erstmal ein Newsletter nochmal irgendwie.
Ich sag dir eins, das wird ein riesen Ding. Das wird eine wertvolle Marke.
Weil was Briefmarkensammler sammeln sind halt einzigartige Marken.
Und so ein Scheiß werden die garantiert kein zweites Mal machen.
Insofern ist das im Prinzip eine klare, also das werden die machen,
dann wird irgendwann einer sagen, seid ihr völlig bekloppt, Leute.
Und dann werden die das nie wieder machen und dann hat man so ein richtiges Unikat.
Also ich habe wirklich Fragen. Also erstens kann ich ein Tape kriegen von dieser
Vorstandssitzung, wo sie das beschlossen haben, wo das gepitcht wurde.
Also ein kürzer Brief mitschicken. Also wer, ja und wann war das?
War das 2019 oder 2020? Das kann natürlich sein. Oh, oh pass auf.
Achso ne du kannst, also ich wollte grad sagen, wenn du dich hier für den Newsletter
anmeldest, kriegst du 5 Euro Gutschein, aber nur wenn du selbstgestaltete Briefmarken machst.
Also ich meine das ist einfach mal, da geht einfach das Buzzhorn geht einfach los, ne.
Durch künstliche Intelligenz erstelltes Brandenburger Tor.
Leute, wirklich, liebe Deutsche Post, ihr habt noch ein okayes Image in der Gesellschaft.
Oder? Sitzen die auch? Deutsche Post? Naja.
Aufregen tun sich alle über die Paketdienste, aber die Post sind ja klug genug DHL weiter zu branden.
Aber so die Deutsche Post, Briefmarken, das ist gemütlich und so,
okay in den Filialen, dann geht's aber nicht so schnell und so,
aber im Prinzip grundsätzlich ist Postbote kein Feind.
Briefmarken sind schön, aber jetzt mit diesem Unsinn daherzukommen,
das ist einfach mal auch sowas von neben der Spur,
also was bitte habt ihr euch dabei gedacht, sorry ich musste das jetzt einfach
kurz reinwerfen, es ist einfach mir hier gerade so über den Bildschirm gelaufen und ich dachte nur WTF.
Man hat ja einiges abzuarbeiten so im Podcast. Also Podcast da ist auf jeden
Fall immer ganz schön was zu verarbeiten. Man muss da irgendwie über alles nachdenken.
Wir blicken ja jetzt, um hier nochmal zum Abschlussthema zu kommen,
wir blicken ja auf fast 20 Jahre Podcastgeschichte schon mittlerweile zurück.
Kann man sich jetzt ein bisschen drüber streiten, wann das wirklich angefangen
hat, so rein technisch gibt's das schon irgendwie noch ein bisschen länger,
Aber dauert ja dann immer alles so ein bisschen, bis ein Name auch mal erfunden wird.
Ich will jetzt hier auch irgendwie kein Jubiläum abfeiern, aber das ist so der
Zeitraum, auf den wir jetzt so schauen, so zwei Jahrzehnte und das ist sagen
wir mal für Internet und Computergeschichte ist das richtig viel mittlerweile.
Ja, jaja, ich würde sagen seit so mit Corona war dann auch in Deutschland irgendwie
jedem klar, was ein Podcast ist.
Gab vorher nochmal so eine Hypewelle international, die immer noch so ein bisschen anhält und so,
mittlerweile ist das ja auch so voll so Business,
aber ich genieße es in gewisser Hinsicht zu beobachten,
dass es so richtig auch nicht gelingt da jetzt so ein mega Hype draus zu machen.
Also das ist zumindest mein Eindruck. Klar es ist ein gehyptes Medium so,
aber es ist halt nicht sofort dann auch komplett unter die Räder gekommen wie
das so bei vielen anderen Sachen der Fall ist.
Und ich finde insofern kann man Podcast feiern, dass sie eigentlich schon noch
so ein bisschen das resistenteste Medium eigentlich sind.
Also so 20 Jahre und es ist eigentlich immer noch im Kern dasselbe was es mal
war, das ist schon irgendwie ganz gut und es hat auch noch Bedeutung und es
hat irgendwie auch immer mehr Bedeutung und es ist true to itself in gewisser Hinsicht.
Ich meine, wenn man mal auf Blogs schaut, gut die gibt es natürlich noch,
aber mal ehrlich, wie viele Blogs liest du noch so regelmäßig?
Ja, also äußerst wenig. Also im Vergleich zu, also Podcast ist immer mehr geworden, ne?
Und Blogs ist auf jeden Fall weniger geworden, ja.
Also es gibt ein Blog, das ich wirklich noch lese.
Ich finde es auch mittlerweile Kandidat für das beste Blog der Welt. Du kennst es auch.
Wir hatten auch schon mal den Autor bei uns in der Sendung.
Das Kraftfuttermischwerk von Ronny, also fantastisch,
wenn ihr das Kraftfuttermischwerk noch nicht entdeckt habt, so,
dann könnt ihr das mal anschauen, weil Kraftfuttermischwerk ist,
sagen wir mal, noch so ein richtiges Blockblock, wie das früher mal war.
Da erscheinen täglich mehrere Meldungen und das Kraftfuttermischwerk,
der Ronny, der kramt die ganze Zeit die schönen Dinge des Internets heraus.
Lustige kleine Meme, die aufploppen, hier mal ein Dokumentarfilm,
wie irgendwie in Japan Haarbürsten hergestellt werden, Irgendwie Wale die irgendwie schöne.
Luftbubbelkreise machen, Rückblicke, kleine irgendwie Werbespots die irgendwie lustig sind,
interessante technische Entwicklungen, jeden Montag gibt's so ein Montaggift
wo irgendjemand auf die Fresse fällt,
also einfach nur zauberhaft und meine Empfehlung ja, also wenn ihr euch immer
schon mal gefragt habt was war das eigentlich mit diesen Blogs und wozu braucht
man das, Kraftfuttermischwerk.de,
einfach fabelhaft, ganz toll, wirklich. Und vor allem auch wirklich die Antithese
zu diesem ganzen durchgehypten Money-Grabbing und Attention-Grabbing-Stuff.
Das ist wirklich auch Slow Food for the Mind.
Also wirklich toll. Also ich habe das so in meinem RSS-Leser und freue mich
einfach wirklich über jeden Post und lege mir die dann auch manchmal extra noch ein bisschen beiseite,
damit ich mir den mal in Ruhe anschauen kann, weil da einfach immer wieder schöne
Sachen drin sind. Einfach wunderbar.
Aber ansonsten, Podcast.
Schönen Gruß an Ronny.
Genau, ist wirklich toll.
Lohnt der Erwähnung in der Kategorie Podcast als Blog.
Wie Podcast aber als Blog.
Naja, aber das war ja so ein bisschen, Blocks waren ja auch so der Wegbereiter,
auch sozial, so wie Blocks sich nach außen gestellt haben, so waren auch Podcasts,
das ist eng, das ist technisch eng miteinander verwandt und ich finde es auch
so atmosphärisch eng miteinander verwandt.
Diese ganze Persönlichkeit, die sich so in Blogs anfangs in dieser Blogosphäre ausgedrückt hat,
das war ja auch so ein bisschen die Geburtsstunde auch dieser ganzen Twittersphäre,
also die ganze deutsche Twitteria, die heute dann auch bei jedem Plattformwechsel
oder bei jedem Hype irgendwie binnen kürzester Zeit aufrückt,
das sind ja immer noch dieselben Leute.
Als hier Clubhouse irgendwie auftrat und irgendwie Invites rumgingen und so,
wer schallerte da innerhalb einer Woche irgendwie rein,
als es so in Deutschland rumging, genau die selben Leute,
die irgendwie zehn Jahre vorher Twitter aufgemacht haben, die jetzt bei Blue
Sky alle reinprasseln und alles kommentieren müssen und so weiter und die vorher
irgendwie alle auf der Republika sich getroffen haben und die alle so einen
Blog hatten und die Blogosphäre gelesen haben.
Das ist einfach immer wieder schön zu sehen, das ist immer so die digitale Stampede,
die da stattfindet und erstmal guckt, was da noch abzugrasen gibt.
Naja und Podcast lief ja dann eine Weile noch so ein bisschen unterm Radar und
das hat sich jetzt irgendwie dann doch geändert in den letzten Jahren.
Und so hat sich natürlich auch diese ganze Finanzierungslandschaft mit geändert
und ich beobachte das immer so mit einigem Interesse,
wie das sich so alles entwickelt, weil ist ja klar,
ich meine gerade wenn man sowas professionell macht, also quasi als Lebensunterhalt,
Da muss man sich natürlich was einfallen lassen und ist auffällig gewesen,
dass insbesondere in den USA wenig überraschend natürlich alles so auf Werbung gesetzt hat.
Das ist in Deutschland nicht ganz so verbreitet aber gibt's auch.
Nicht ganz so verbreitet.
In Deutschland?
Also ich müsste jetzt, also welche Podcasts kennst du denn noch,
die nicht werbefinanziert sind?
Also neben Logbuch Netzpolitik vielleicht noch der Podcast von Netzpolitik.org
mit dem wir nichts zu tun haben an dieser Stelle nochmal freundlichen Gruß.
Irgendwann können wir mal die ganzen Spenden, die bei euch ankommen auch rüberrücken.
Ich sag nicht, es ist nicht verbreitet, ich sag nur, es ist nicht.
Dann noch die Podcast des öffentlich-rechtlichen Rotfunk Deutschlandfunk oder so.
Aber ich kann nicht behaupten, dass ich viele deutschsprachige werbefreie Podcasts hätte.
Ich habe sie jetzt auch nicht durchgezählt. Ich persönlich klinke dann auch
immer mental ein bisschen aus, wenn irgendwo mit Werbung geklingelt wird.
Es gibt aber auch Ausnahmen.
Also ich höre auch Podcasts, wo es Werbung gibt. Nicht gerne, aber...
Und ich fand das auf jeden Fall ganz interessant, wie das sich so in den letzten
Jahren auch so entwickelt hat,
weil es gab ja dann noch so einen zweiten Trend, so auf mehreren Standbeinen zu stehen,
mal wurden nach Spenden gefragt, mal wurden so Membership-Modelle gepusht,
dann kam halt die Werbung und manche Podcasts machen halt alles,
so all diese ganzen Sachen, aber es scheint sich so ein bisschen was zu ändern.
Ist kein großes Geheimnis.
Würdest du ATP zu deinen Lieblingspodcasts zählen?
Lieblingspodcasts schwere, also genau, wenn du sagst zu meinen Lieblingspodcasts,
ich würde aber grundsätzlich sagen, wenn ich fast alle Podcasts,
die ich abonniert habe, sind meine Lieblingspodcasts.
Sonst würde ich sie ja nicht abonnieren.
Aber kann auf jeden Fall sagen, dass ATP ein,
angenehmer, einsichtsreicher, gut formulierter, progressiver,
Wenn sie sich mal politisch äußern, dann immer durchaus sehr progressiv und reflektiert.
Auch wenn es kein, ja doch, also kann man schon sagen,
höre ich gerne und ja, natürlich auch Nutzer der App, der Overcast App von Marco
Arment, schreibt die ja, glaube ich, seit vielen Jahren.
LTP, Accidental Tech Podcast, ist auch schon richtig lange unterwegs,
hat sich so über verschiedene Ecken gegründet,
wie auch immer, kennt ihr oder kennt ihr nicht so, und die haben dann aber jüngst,
und deswegen fand ich das Thema auch nochmal so aufgreifenswert,
auch nochmal selber dazu geäußert, wie sie das eigentlich selber machen und
haben berichtet, dass dieses Werbemodell offensichtlich nicht mehr so gut funktioniert.
Weil ihr Werbemodell war nämlich auch eines, was sich ein bisschen unterschieden hat,
dass sie quasi ihre Werbung selber vermarktet haben und das können sich eigentlich
nur wenige Podcasts noch leisten,
aber auch das Modell scheint nicht mehr so gut zu funktionieren,
weil es halt so langsam einen Trend gibt,
der mehr hin zu den Plattformen geht und die Plattformen,
also Spotify und so weiter die halt in irgendeiner Form versuchen so Podcast-Hoster
für alle Podcast zu sein,
die dann natürlich das über ihre eigenen Systeme ausspielen,
dann von der Ursprungstechnik ein bisschen abweichen, nicht mehr auf RSS basieren,
dafür natürlich dann sehr viel mehr Daten sehen,
auswerten können, Hörprofile bilden können,
all dieser ganze Kram, was man dann eben so macht, das heißt das Nutzerverhalten
genau auszuleuchten und dann natürlich über die Accounts und die Metadaten der
Personen dann auch genau sagen kann,
okay, Hörer in diesem Alterssegment mit dem Geschlecht und so weiter mit diesen
Vorlieben hörten in diesem Podcast das und das und so weiter und diese ganze
Geschichte und das ist ja dann quasi diese Basis für die moderne Werbeausspielung.
Und weil das dann eben auch in zunehmendem Maße bedeutet, dass du dann einfach
nur noch so deinen Podcast zur Bewerbung ausschreibst,
aber überhaupt nicht mehr darüber entscheidest, wer letzten Endes bei dir sendet,
gibst du dann quasi die Kontrolle darüber, was eigentlich wirklich letzten Endes
der Inhalt deiner Sachen ist.
Und das passte ihnen nicht.
Also es ist ja noch viel schlimmer,
dass du den Inhalt, also die Kontrolle über deinen Inhalt abgibst,
sondern du wirst ja auch einfach dann so ein Content-Lieferant für so eine Plattform, ja.
Also die ja erstmal, einen Podcast kannst du selber hosten, das war die Idee.
Niemand hat gesagt, lass uns mal Podcast erfinden,
dann können wir Spotify, Amazon,
Originals oder irgend so einen Scheiß machen, sondern Leute haben gesagt,
lass uns in RSS Feeds, Enclosures aufnehmen und damit halt einfach ein Format
definieren, wie man Audiodateien abonnieren kann und dann kann man Play drücken
und man hat vollständige Freiheit über seinen Player.
Und vollständige Freiheit, wo man diesen Feed hinlegt. Das war ja mal die Idee, ja.
Und dann gibt's Leute, die das selber vermarkten wollen. Okay,
ist in Ordnung. Gibt Leute, die andere Modelle haben.
Und mit Sicherheit, wenn du dich jetzt auf irgendeine Spotify-Plattform oder sonst was begibst,
die dann da Zielgruppen-Targeting machen und irgendwelche Ad-Analysen und wer hört jetzt hier zu,
ah, sie wollen eine, ihre Werbung soll, was weiß ich, Männer im Alter von zwanzig
bis dreizehn, weiß ich, treffen, kein Problem, dann spielen wir das in Auto,
Computer und sonst was rein.
Du gibst ja alles aus der Hand und fütterst nur noch diese Leute mit.
Du gibst ja nicht nur die Kontrolle über den Kontext ab, sondern du dienst mit
deinen Inhalten auch einer Plattform, deren Ziel zunächst einmal ist,
diese Plattform zu sein und nicht etwa dir Geld zu geben.
Na, also, ah, sorry.
Naja, also das sind alles so Aspekte, die jetzt hier mit reinkommen.
Ich meine, diese individuelle Werbeausspielung, das ist dann wiederum an meinen
Augen so ein amerikanisches Ding.
Darf ich da auch noch ganz kurz was zu sagen?
Ja, bitte.
Selbst den Podcast vermarkten finde ich in Ordnung.
Wir haben auch hier schon öfter mal darüber gesprochen. Und ich halte dieses Werbung einsprechen.
Für ungefähr die perfideste Form der Werbung. Das möchte ich aber immer noch
dazu sagen. Habe ich, glaube ich, schon öfter gesagt.
Und so sehr mir der Gedanke gefällt und ich es auch sehr unterstützenswert finde,
dass die Jungs von ATP ihre eigene Marke und Firma und Fairmarktung sind.
Und man hört ja dann auch immer, dass sie auch davon sprechen,
dass sie sehr lange Beziehungen zu ihren Sponsorinnen haben,
die es teilweise über Jahre, kann es auch irgendwann nicht mehr hören,
Lennoth, man ey schon wieder.
Aber oft das auch benutzen, also auch berichtlich.
Ja und dann sagen, genau wir benutzen das selber und da beginnt natürlich,
da wird das natürlich so ein bisschen fuzzy.
Bei ATP ist das immer noch in einem Rahmen, den ich in Ordnung finde,
weil die eben auch sagen, ja pass auf, das ist ein Produkt, das,
Also die können sich noch dazu leisten offenbar, entweder richtig gut zu lügen
oder nur Sponsoren zu haben, die deren Produkte sie auch wirklich selber nutzen oder so, ja.
Es gibt dann so andere Sachen, wenn du jetzt irgendwie Twit hörst oder so,
wo du schon auch so ein bisschen merkst, dass sie da halt irgendwie runterleiern,
was die Anzeigenabteilung verkauft hat, so ungefähr.
Gibt's auch. Ganz grundsätzlich finde ich das aber nicht vollständig unkritisch, dass die da ihre...
Da gibt's ja auch so einen Begriff für Hosted Ads oder sowas,
dass sie also im Prinzip die vertraute Stimme wegen der Menschen den Podcast hören,
deren Urteil sie vertrauen, zu der sie ja irgendwie eine Form von Beziehung
haben im Sinne von die höre ich oft oder die höre ich lange,
diese Stimme ist mir vertraut, die kann ich einschätzen, die kommt mir bekannt
vor, dass man das zum Verkauf stellt.
Ich will da jetzt gar nicht tief ins Detail gehen, aber das möchte ich,
muss ich immer an der Stelle anmerken, dass das auch nicht vollständig unkritisch zu sehen ist.
Nee und das, gut dass du das ansprichst,
ich hätte es jetzt auch angesprochen, man kann darüber geteilter Meinung sein,
also es gibt da, sagen wir mal auch in den USA generell kulturell einfach deutlich
weniger Berührungsprobleme mit Werbung.
Das ist da einfach viel mehr in der Kultur drin. So ist es einfach.
In Deutschland würde ich auch sagen, ist es auf der anderen Seite auch manchmal
nicht ganz nachvollziehbar extrem dagegen.
Wir haben hier irgendwie andere Vorstellungen und andere kulturelle Neigungen
und hier drückt sich das so aus, dort drückt sich das so aus.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz, ich habe mir die Frage natürlich auch gestellt.
Über die Jahre immer wieder so die Frage mit,
okay was sind jetzt so der korrekte Modus und was würde ich denn jetzt tun und
was würde ich denn nicht tun und was passt und ich denke ich hab auch mal über
alles irgendwann mal nachgedacht so.
Über Sponsoren, Partner, keine Ahnung, über verkaufte Podcasts so,
also es ist alles mal durch meinen Kopf gerollt und ich hab alles mal ein bisschen
auf mich wirken lassen und versucht da selber eine Position zuzufinden.
Und am Ende hat mir das alles nicht groß gefallen.
Wo es jetzt so ein bisschen so einen Übergang gibt und das ist ja zum Beispiel jetzt auch das Modell,
deswegen erwähne ich das auch, deswegen erwähne ich jetzt auch gerade explizit
diese Diskussion, die die bei LTP auch selber geführt haben in dieser Folge,
das ist jetzt schon ein paar Wochen her.
Sollen wir mal den Link raussuchen auf die folgende ganz interessante Debatte.
Sie sagen halt okay hier dieses Werbemodell funktioniert zunehmend weniger für uns.
Wir sind auch mittlerweile, also die haben ja auch teilweise in den letzten
Jahren alle ihre Jobs aufgegeben und voll auf diesen Podcast konzentriert,
was wirklich ziemlich bemerkenswert ist.
So und sehen aber jetzt, okay funktioniert jetzt nicht mehr,
wir wollen jetzt mehr auf dieses Membership-Modell setzen.
Also wir wollen sozusagen mehr unseren Podcast verkaufen, eine direkte Beziehung
zu haben. Und das ist ja übrigens auch das, was mich an Werbung immer so stört,
ist in dem Moment, wo du Werbung Teil deines Finanzierungsmodells,
machst.
Mal ganz abgesehen von solchen Aspekten, dass es irgendwie creepy ist,
wenn du jetzt auch noch selber die Werbung auch noch vorträgst, aber selbst wenn dir,
wie auch immer die Werbung sozusagen präsent ist, dann führt es halt dazu,
dass du quasi deine, dass deine Kunden nicht mehr die Leute sind,
zu denen du sprichst, sondern deine Kunden sind sozusagen die Leute,
die dir das Geld dafür geben, dass du, während du zu anderen Leuten sprichst,
deren Botschaft einbaust.
Und dann verschiebt sich halt alles was im Kopf. Ich hatte zum Beispiel auch
über ein paar Jahre bei der Freakshow so diese typischen Amazon Affiliate Links drin.
Und das ist natürlich auch so eine Sache, gut da kann man sagen okay,
das ist ja nur im Blog, das ist ja in den Shownotes, das hat jetzt sozusagen
nichts mit dem eigentlichen Content zu tun, das ist so eine sekundäre Geschichte
und niemand wird gezwungen und lalala, ne.
Trotzdem merkst du dann auch, wenn du das machst so,
dann bemühst du dich dann vielleicht doch nochmal irgendwie irgendein Produkt zu erwähnen,
weil du weißt, naja dann kannst du dann aber da einen Link drauf machen und
wenn das jemand haben will, dann kauft er das und dann kriegst du da deinen Anteil davon.
Das geht ganz automatisch und als ich das gespürt habe,
dass ich auf einmal so ein Verlangen würde ich jetzt nicht sagen,
so ein Incentive auf einmal gespürt habe im Nacken, mit das ich das jetzt tun
wollen würde, wurde mir das unangenehm.
Ich muss zugeben, dass ich es dann vielleicht nicht sofort habe sein lassen,
ich hab nur gemerkt wie unwohl mir dabei wurde, am Ende hat mich Amazon sowieso
irgendwann rausgeschmissen,
dann ist mir die Entscheidung auch so ein bisschen abgenommen worden,
aber es ist definitiv so, man merkt einfach sofort in dem Moment wo dich die
Kohle lenkt, dann gehst du dahin wo die Kohle herkommt und dann ist das irgendwie
das Lied was du singst und das ist irgendwie unangenehm.
Ich find's persönlich auf jeden Fall unangenehm. Diese Membership-Modelle sind
natürlich jetzt insofern ganz gut,
dass du sagst okay, wenn ihr irgendwie keinen Bock auf die Werbung habt und
wenn ihr vielleicht noch andere Vergnügungen haben wollt,
wie eine Postshow, Preshow, keine Ahnung, Livestream, Mitschnitt,
bevor die Sendung schon final geschnitten ist, damit ihr es irgendwie ganz früh
hören könnt, so dann gibt's hier irgendwie Membership und mit diesem Membership
erkauft ihr euch quasi die Leistung einer gesonderten Darreichung.
Also ohne störende Zusatzinhalte und eben vielleicht noch weitere kleinere Sachen,
die so in einem normalen kostenlosen Paket nicht mit drin sind.
Kann man machen, finde ich auch irgendwie nix wildes dran,
heißt aber natürlich auch, dass man sich unter Umständen nochmal mehr Arbeit
macht, irgendwie nochmal so ein Belohnungsprodukt rauszutun und das ist dann
halt auch wieder etwas, was dann deine Zeit wieder in Anspruch nimmt.
Dann muss das ja auch geliefert werden, dann hast du irgendwie ein Leistungsversprechen abgegeben,
dann musst du irgendwie das auch tun und was ist, wenn du das dann nicht schaffst,
dann sind alle böse und dann entsteht halt auch wiederum so eine Spannung finde
ich jetzt zwischen der Community,
Hörern und dir, Weil auf einmal so eine Erwartungshaltung im Raum ist,
die du aber selber deklariert hast, qua dieses Vertrags, den man dann sozusagen abgibt.
Wenn du mir so und so viel Geld gibst pro Monat, dann kriegst du auch das und
das. Weil das ist letzten Endes genau das, was ja dann stattfindet.
Gut, das machen die, kann man machen,
machen auch einige andere, so Dienste wie Memberful und so weiter,
die im Netz einem da die Arbeit für abnehmen, für dieses ganze User registrieren
und so weiter, die spielen natürlich dann noch hilfreich mit rein.
Ja, also Werbung so ein bisschen auf dem Backburner, weil man sich jetzt in
zunehmendem Maße verkaufen muss an einen Werbemarkt, der eigentlich an dem eigenen
Inhalt kein Interesse hat.
Orientierung hin zu Mitgliedschaften und Mehrwertsverkauf, beziehungsweise die,
die sich das dann nicht leisten können oder wollen, die müssen dann sozusagen
das mit Werbung nehmen, keine Ahnung.
Also für uns hier bei Logbuch Netzpolitik ist es irgendwie so nix und generell
gilt das natürlich auch für meine ganzen Sachen,
die ich bei der Meta-Ebene mache, also ich fühle mich irgendwie immer noch am
wohlsten damit zu sagen,
Ich möchte gerne einfach ein direktes,
eine direkte Beziehung haben sozusagen zu der Hörgemeinschaft,
weil ich einfach das Gefühl hab, dann denke ich da richtig drüber nach,
dann fühle ich darüber so und ich fühle mich dann irgendwie schlecht,
wenn ich irgendwie eine schlechte Sendung gemacht habe,
Ich fühle mich schlecht,
wenn ich irgendwie zu wenig mache oder mir nicht genug Mühe gegeben habe oder
im Schnitt nicht gut war, also das ist schon so der Punkt, wo es für mich dann
irgendwie kritisch wird.
Einblicke wie Tim hier alles belastet ne, wenn er nicht gut war im Schnitt, das belastet den Tim.
Ja natürlich belastet den Tim. Ja das könnt ihr euch auch mal ein bisschen anerkennen.
Ich hab nicht das Gefühl keine Anerkennung zu bekommen. Das tut dem Tim mehr
weh als euch in den Ohren. Ja, aber sowas ist mir halt wichtig,
weil das ist sozusagen der Vektor.
Weil ich ja auch weiß, dadurch, dass ich auf alle anderen Modelle verzichte,
Ja, also ich verkaufe halt nicht irgendwas und so weiter, ich mache auch kein
Leistungsversprechen,
sondern das Modell trägt sich nur dadurch, dass ich irgendwie erfühlen kann,
was wohl das Richtige ist.
Fast zwanzig Jahre mach ich das jetzt und irgendwie basiert alles auf einem Gefühl.
So ein Gefühl, was man irgendwie gar nicht so richtig klar erklären kann und
was zu der Gründung all dieser ganzen Sendungen geführt hat,
was dazu geführt hat, dass wir Logbuch Netzpolitik angefangen haben und auch
dazu geführt hat, dass wir Logbuch Netzpolitik halt auch weitermachen und eben
es sich genauso entwickelt hat, wie es sich eben jetzt letzten Endes entwickelt hat.
Entwickelt hat und ich habe kein Interesse daran, irgendeinen dieser anderen
Wege jetzt irgendwie aufzumachen, so.
Und das, finde ich, kann eben auch funktionieren.
Das funktioniert vielleicht nicht für alle, gar keine Frage,
aber ich weiß nicht, mein Leben ist gepflastert von einem Weg,
der nicht für andere Leute funktioniert, also das ist immer schon alles ein
bisschen hausgemacht gewesen.
Und ich fühle mich irgendwie besser damit, wenn sozusagen das Modell ist mit,
gibt es überhaupt einen Namen dafür, für dieses Modell, also sozusagen so ein,
es lebt nur wenn alle glücklich sind. Spenden basiert vielleicht?
Ich glaube das nennt sich Spenden basiert?
Ja.
Lebt nur so lange wie es Spenden gibt?
Ja ist klar, aber was ist sozusagen die Motivation für die Spenden?
Also es muss ja sozusagen keiner was. Also es gibt ja alles kostenlos,
auch wenn man es nicht zahlt.
Das einzige, ja gut,
ich meine, was ich meine, was ist die Beschreibung für dieses psychologische
Moment, was da sozusagen im Raum steht, für diese Bindung.
Du bist doch Psychologe, musst das doch wissen.
Stockholmsyndrom, bei mir jetzt oder bei allen anderen?
Aber meistens wenn man nicht genau weiß was es ist, dann ist Stockholmsyndrom die richtige Antwort.
Ich halte euch alle gefangen. Und ihr denkt nur ihr findet mich toll.
Aber eigentlich bin ich der Tyran, jetzt müsste ich so eine Rede halten wie bei Pulp Fiction.
Genau. Jetzt gibt's ja auch noch ähnliche Modelle, die so ein bisschen da so
reingehen, Plattformen wie Patreon zum Beispiel, es gab ja früher auch mal Flatter,
fand ich ja mal ganz toll.
Stimmt.
Ist mittlerweile nur noch, sie haben irgendwie ihr Konzept zum x-ten mal geändert,
ich hab's überhaupt nicht mehr verstanden, also das ist wirklich dead,
aber was ja ein totaler Star ist,
ist ja dieses Patreon muss man sagen, also das funktioniert ja auch mega gut und Patreon,
Das kennt ihr ja sicherlich, das ist in dieser YouTube Welt groß geworden,
das waren so YouTuber die das aufgezogen haben, das war eine super Idee.
Aber im Prinzip auch so dieses, ja, gebt doch einfach ein bisschen Geld ab um
sozusagen alles am laufen zu halten und ihr könnt auch mehrere Leute unterstützen
und ihr zahlt hier nur einmal Kohle und wir verteilen das wieder.
Ähnliche Idee wie Flattern, nur Flatter war ein bisschen zu verkopft,
zu technisch am Ende, weil zu unflexibel.
Und Patrion hat glaube ich zwei Sachen ganz gut verstanden. Erstens,
man will nicht einen Betrag gleichmäßig verteilen,
sondern man will auch schon gewichten können und zweitens, was Patrion auch
verstanden hat, ist, dass sie die Creator so in den Mittelpunkt genommen haben.
Also sozusagen hier präsentier dich, erzähl was über dich etc.
Also es gibt dann sozusagen so eine Front. Das hat ja Flatter nie gemacht.
Es gab nie so richtige Profiles, Pages oder irgendwie sowas.
Keine Ahnung warum sie das nicht gemacht haben. Ich war mal irgendwann mal da
in Malmö und hab denen mal so einen Talk gehalten, was meiner Meinung nach sie
alles machen sollte. Da war das auch mit dabei, aber haben sie nicht gemacht.
Naja, und dann gibt es in Deutschland noch Steady, was ja auch ähnlich funktioniert wie Patreon.
Das benutzen ja auch mittlerweile so einige, auch in der Podcast Landschaft
und das finde ich auch gut, weil das sozusagen auch so ein regelmäßiges Ding ist.
Das ist ein bisschen problematisch, weil diese Dienste dann aus rechtlichen
Gründen dann auch wieder so ein Leistungsversprechen machen müssen, Etc.
Aber das ist da. Genau und das war nämlich auch noch so ein Ding,
ich hab neulich so eine Mail bekommen, ich weiß nicht, unterstützt du irgendwas
über Steady, da gab's dann irgendwie auch so eine Mail mit so,
ja hallo hier du unterstützt ja irgendwie x und y, wie wärs denn mal mit einem Inflationsausgleich?
Ja hätte ich auch gerne.
War ja auch ein interessanter Spin und so, weil klar wenn ich natürlich irgendwie
auf eine regelmäßige Zahlung irgendwo eingelassen hast,
so die dann, also das funktioniert ja auch so ein bisschen aus dieser Laziness
heraus, Und dann richst du es einmal ein und denkst dir so okay läuft und wenn
jetzt nicht irgendwas ganz schlimmes passiert, dann änderst du es halt auch erstmal nicht.
Und trotz alledem, um sozusagen steigende Kosten in irgendeiner Form abfangen
zu können, wäre natürlich so ein Inflationsausgleich auch ganz nett.
Da hätte ich auch nichts dagegen.
Ja aber grundsätzlich denke ich funktioniert dieses Modell noch und mich macht
das halt sehr glücklich,
weil eben all diese ganzen anderen Faktoren dann nicht dann mit drin sind so
und ich glaube das ist für uns auch immer eine gute Basis gewesen so dass wir
irgendwie eigentlich jedes mal wenn wir jetzt hier an den Start gehen und sagen so hier,
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer Tralala wir legen jetzt wieder los,
dass wir irgendwie frei aus unserem aktuellen mentalen Zustand heraus mit so
einer scheiß drauf Mentalität so ein bisschen durch die News gehen und unseren
Senf zum Lauf der Welt abgeben können oder?
Wir lenken den Lauf der Welt? Nein, das können wir uns nicht...
Also ich, wir haben ja immer mal wieder zu regelmäßigen Abständen reden wir zum Beispiel darüber,
dass ich, dass mich natürlich diese Spotifys und sonst was alle total nerven,
dass ich vor allem auch leider, das ist ja der Teil, den ich mehr bemängele
oder den ich mehr bedauere als du teilweise, Dass ich halt schon einfach weiß,
wie viele Hörerinnen und Hörer uns da auch einfach flöten gehen.
Also die uns einfach nie erfahren.
Weil zu denen Podcasts gekommen sind, weil ihnen irgendwann eine freundliche
Stimme ins Ohr gesagt hat, ey du musst ja nicht nur Musik hören,
du kannst auch Podcasts hören.
Oder die Podcasts vielleicht erst nur darüber kennengelernt haben und gar keine
Vorstellung davon haben, dass das was ist, was es auch noch woanders gibt.
Genau, jaja, das ist regelmäßig so. Ach, wie, du machst einen Podcast?
Also, ich find den nicht. Also, wo suchst du denn?
Ja, hier, Spotify. Also, ja, es ist ein Podcast, nicht ein von mir gespendeter
Content für Spotify, so ne? Ja, wie, hä?
Also das ist ja, dem kann man halt hinterher trauern.
Gleichzeitig habe ich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt Interesse, sagen wir mal,
mit dem, das Werk, Logbuch, was wir hier geschaffen haben, was wir jetzt hier
irgendwie seit bald zwölf Jahren pflegen.
Und das, oder die Institution, Meta-Ebene, die du seit bald 20 Jahren pflegst,
jetzt untergehen zu lassen, nur weil man sich nicht auf neue Marktbedingungen
im weitesten Sinne anpasst, ne.
Das heißt, ich im Gegensatz zu dir halte ich mich ja noch bedeckt mit der Aussage,
niemals auf diesen Plattformen vertreten zu sein.
Aber gleichzeitig habe ich wie du auch die.
Den Stolz daran, das zumindest bisher vermieden zu haben und ohne das bestehen zu können.
Da sind wir natürlich in einer ähnlichen, wenn auch sicherlich bei weitem nicht
so privilegierten Position wie ATP,
dass wir eben auch nicht darauf angewiesen sind, das so zu machen.
Wir sind nicht darauf angewiesen, auf eine Werbeplattform zu gehen.
Also ich sag auch nicht niemals, ich kann mir durchaus auch eine Situation vorstellen,
wo ich mich dazu genötigt sehe.
Wenn's ganz schlimm kommt, gibt's hier Werbung, so Leute. Also ich drohe das jetzt hier mit an.
Könnt ihr euch überlegen. Ja aber da bin ich gar nicht hin. Davon möchte ich
gerne von frei gekauft werden. Genau.
Gleichzeitig, ich habe nur diesen einen Podcast. Ich bin mit dem zufrieden.
Der ist für mich der, ja, das ist so viel Podcast, wie ich machen will.
Ja, also viel mehr möchte ich auch nicht. Oder, also, Oder aktuell kann ich
jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich, natürlich habe ich immer mal wieder Ideen für Podcasts,
aber mir fehlt auch sicherlich, also ganz klar die Zeit.
Sorry, ich spiel hier mit Kügelchen rum.
Magneten.
Ich muss aufhören.
Bist du nervös oder was?
Nee, ich hab hier so ein Magnetding.
Zwei, drei Hörer wissen auch, was das ist, die mir das auch schon mit Magneten gespielt haben.
Insofern mir ist eigentlich, mir persönlich ist so am Fortbestand dieses Podcasts
sehr gelegen und zu diesem Fortbestand gehört auch,
dass der, naja, sag ich mal, dass die, die ganze Arbeit,
die wir da reinstecken, in irgendeiner Weise auch, ja,
Anerkennung findet in Form von vielen Hörerinnen und Hörern und natürlich auch
der einen oder anderen Spende, E-Mail und sonstigen Anerkennungen,
die uns so ab und zu mal zuteil wird.
Wir haben ja auch ein Spendenaufkommen hier, das, habe ich glaube ich auch immer
gesagt, für mich sicherlich nicht zum Leben reicht.
Also von diesem Podcast könnte ich nicht leben.
Aber natürlich trotzdem eine ausreichende Motivation als Zubrot ist, das hier zu machen.
Ich nehme mir diese Zeit ja trotz eines Vollzeitjobs, den ich ebenfalls gerne mache.
Und ich finde teilweise eben auch, auch da sind wir unterschiedlicher Ansicht,
ich glaube nicht, dass ich den Anspruch erheben würde, nur von diesem Podcast
leben zu können, das wäre mir dann doch noch ein zu geringer Wertbeitrag.
Und ein bisschen, also weißt du, dass ich jetzt sagen würde,
so ich mache aber jetzt einen Podcast und ich erhebe jetzt den Anspruch vor
diesem einen Podcast zu leben.
Wenn jetzt andere Leute irgendwie mehrere machen und so, ne,
dann kann ich das auch irgendwo verstehen,
wie jetzt bei dir, ne, eine Reihe an Podcast-Outputs, die in unterschiedlichen
Frequenzen erscheinen,
da kann ich das auch, da kann man dann irgendwann sagen,
ich bin jetzt hauptberuflicher Podcaster, Aber es gibt einige Podcaster,
die ich eigentlich auch gerne höre, wo ich mir denke so,
also für das, was ihr hier liefert, darauf jetzt den Anspruch zu haben,
davon jetzt leben zu wollen und auch das auf allen Wegen zu vermarkten und einen
mit Werbung voll zu ballern und noch nach Spenden zu bellen und so,
da bin ich auch ganz froh, dass ich da noch nicht bin, ja.
Also sorry, ne wirklich, da bin ich ganz froh, das klingt jetzt total arrogant,
aber da bin ich auch einfach ganz froh, dass ich noch ein bisschen etwas höheren
Anspruch an mich selber habe.
Okay, naja also ich, Sorry, ich hab mich extra still gehalten zu dem Thema,
weil ich wusste, dass ich potenziell, wenn ich jetzt hier meine Meinung sage,
die vielleicht für ein bisschen Schweigen sorgt.
Aber ne, ich möchte das auch vor allem gerne machen, ja, also um,
sorry, um den Bezug zu dem zu kriegen, was du sagst, ja.
Ich möchte das gerne machen und das ist seit zwölf Jahren der Fall.
Ich glaube, es gibt nichts, was ich, vielleicht Fahrrad fahren,
was ich ähnlich lange so gerne mache.
Podcast.
Zu geilen Fahrradfahrern. Also sagen wir mal, es gibt natürlich schon ein paar
Sachen, die man ein Leben lang gerne macht. Und die muss ich jetzt auch gar nicht alle aufzählen.
Aber sagen wir mal, zumindest in dieser Besetzung so lange ich das so gerne mache.
Die Bilder sind sowieso jetzt schon im Kopf, da kannst du gar nichts mehr zu machen.
Das ist euer Kopf.
Ich wiederum, ich probier das halt schon seit einiger Zeit und es funktioniert ganz okay,
das zu machen, weil ich halt auch vor allem die Freiheiten, die damit verbunden sind,
auch so ein bisschen als Bezahlung ansehe, weil ich hab halt nicht 9 to 5 und
kann mir einfach so meine Zeit, Ich wäre froh über Nein to Five.
To Five wäre mir jetzt auch gar nicht so ein Problem, aber Nein ist manchmal ganz schön hart.
Also ich taug ja eh nicht für eine normale Firma von daher musste ich mir ja
schon immer was anderes einfallen lassen.
Naja gut, jetzt können wir den Gedankengang ja vielleicht auch abschließen,
wir wollten einfach mal so ein bisschen über unsere Haltung dazu glaube ich sprechen,
gerade weil eben um uns herum gefühlt, so gerade eben in so Podcasts an denen uns auch was liegt,
so die Dinge ein bisschen anders machen, aber eben interessante Positionen haben,
da eben das ganze so thematisiert wurde und weil es halt einfach auch so ein
Trend ist der letzten Jahre, der sich so langsam so weiterentwickelt.
Also ob Steady, Patreon und so weiter, ich werde manchmal gefragt,
ob ich sowas nicht auch machen wollen würde.
Da bin ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht so sicher immer,
weil mit diesen ganzen Plattformen kommt ja sozusagen auch nochmal wieder Arbeit
dazu, weil dann irgendwie alle bespielt werden, dann musst du irgendwie überall
posten, dann musst du dich an irgendwelche Regeln halten und so weiter.
Das finde ich auch alles wieder anstrengend.
Von daher bin ich ganz froh damit mit dem Modus,
den wir jetzt hier haben und natürlich würde ich mich sehr freuen darüber,
wenn ihr eure Unterstützung, die ihr schon leistet,
weiterführen würdet, eure vielleicht noch nicht existierende Unterstützung vielleicht
mal erwägt oder vielleicht sogar einen Inflationsausgleich macht,
das ist ein schönes Wort oder?
Butter 93. Butter 93.
Hab ich gesehen. Butter 93.
Butter 93. Butter kostet 93.
Weiß ich nicht was Butter kostet.
Naja aber auf jeden Fall.
Aber ich meine anstatt nach mehr zu fragen, sag mal Inflationsausgleich. Ja.
20 Prozent Inflationsausgleich.
So fettgefressend von eurer Kohle. Ich bin so aufgegangen.
Die ganze Inflation hier, die muss ja ausgeglichen werden.
Naja, nur kurzer Hinweis, wenn ihr da LNP dran schreibt an eure Spende, kriege ich was ab.
Aber der will ja nicht Podcaster, richtiger Podcaster werden,
der davon lebt, also nicht übertreiben.
Also ich weiß nicht, also ich hab, also um das vielleicht gerade noch ein bisschen
zu ergänzen, was ich da gesagt habe, ich habe einmal in meinem Leben den Fehler
gemacht, mein Hobby zum Beruf zu machen, und das war mit dem Hacken.
Und das ist schön. Ich bin ja von Beruf,
IT-Security-Fuzzi und gleichzeitig kann ich aber schon sagen,
dass das insgesamt nicht so empfehlenswert ist,
sein Hobby zum Beruf zu machen, weil Weil man dann nämlich ein neues Hobby braucht.
Hobbys halten, also man braucht dann eben Neues. Und das ist das,
was man dann jetzt als Hobby hatte, ist dann auf einmal Beruf.
Das ist nicht schlimm, aber das hat eine Folge.
Also in meinem Beispiel jetzt hier, IT Security als Beruf, heißt,
ich muss das auch manchmal machen, wenn ich da vielleicht gar nicht so Bock drauf hab.
Und das haben Hobbys nicht. Das ist einfach nicht so. Wenn du ein Hobby hast
und da sagt einer, heute golfen, du hast keinen Bock auf golfen,
dann gehst du halt nicht golfen.
So, wenn das jetzt dein Hobby ist. Ich weiß nicht, was andere Menschen für Hobbys
haben. Oder Fahrradfahren.
Regnet, fahr ich nicht Fahrrad. Ich fahr nur nicht mal Regenfahrrad.
Hast du schon mal Golf gespielt?
Tim, sehe ich aus, als hätte ich Platzreife.
Ich frage ja nur, ob du schon mal Golf gespielt hast.
Sehe ich aus, als würde ich vom Parkplatz eines Golfplatzes den Weg bis rein
gehen können, ohne dass irgendjemand mich festhält und fragt,
was ich in Mar-a-Lago will?
Ich glaube, du kommst auch nicht weiter als ich.
Ich war ein paar Mal auf der Driving Range.
Was ist das?
Das ist wo man den Ball wegschlagen übt mit dem großen Schläger.
Ah ok. Ich hatte glaube ich in meinem Leben noch nicht mal einen Golfschläger
in der Hand und übrigens auch noch nie einen Tennisschläger interessanterweise.
Tennisschläger hatte ich schon mal in der Hand, hab aber schon mal Tennis versucht zu spielen.
Ja, das hab ich auch noch nicht gemacht. Also ich bin ja durchaus Sportarten
aufgeschlossen gegenüber, komischerweise, aber ausgerechnet Tennis und Golf
war bisher noch nicht so in meinem Ding. Aber wir kommen ein bisschen ab.
Hobby zum Beruf machen, ist so eine Sache,
ja, in diesem Falle oder im aktuellen Falle, im Falle des Podcasting entscheide
ich mich dagegen oder ist das, möchte ich das, ist das aktuell nicht mein Plan, ja.
Und ich würde es mir sehr genau überlegen, ob ich das wirklich möchte,
weil ich genauso wie ich hier gerne rede, gibt es Phasen, in denen ich das einfach mal ungerne tue.
Und insofern habe ich gerade keine Bestrebungen, Vollzeit-Podcaster zu sein.
Und ich glaube, dass das ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr gutes Modell ist,
was wir haben, um das jetzt gerade ganz kurz noch abzurunden.
Nämlich einen professionellen Partner zu haben,
der, was die Techniken angeht,
da das Ökosystem ja auch mitgeprägt hat, über Podlove und diese ganzen Dinge,
die aus dieser Community auch entstanden sind und gepflegt werden.
Jemand, der auch darauf achtet, dass wir hier
professionell arbeiten und damit einen wichtigen Grundstein für den Erfolg dieses
Projektes liegt und gleichzeitig von meiner Seite in den Genuss dieser Professionalität
in der Produktion zu kommen,
Ohne meinerseits dieses Vollzeit professionelle Engagement zeigen zu müssen. Weißt du?
Also damit entlastest du ja auch mich. Ja ich bin ja von Anfang an,
Logbuch Netzpolitik Folge 1 wurde in einem Studio aufgenommen. In der Meta-Ebene.
Mit teilweise dem gleichen Equipment wie heute noch. Wobei ich glaube die Headsets
wurden ein paar mal durchgetauscht inzwischen.
Ich glaube das dicke Yamaha-Pult oder was du da hast, das stand da damals schon und das ist ein Teil,
den andere sich erarbeiten müssen, verdienen müssen oder so,
wir haben auch natürlich von Anfang an eine relativ hohe Hörerschaft für die,
Für die erste Folge gehabt, einfach nur weil du erwähnt hast,
es gibt einen neuen Podcast von mir.
Also ich glaube die erste Folge Logbuch Netzpolitik hatte, sag ich mal,
Abrufzahlen von denen andere Projekte nach langer Zeit noch träumen.
Insofern habe ich da ja sehr sehr viel von profitiert. Insofern fühle ich mich
jetzt gar nicht so schlecht, wenn ich sage, ich möchte das nicht Vollzeit machen.
Das ist meine persönliche Präferenz.
Für mich ist das irgendwie ein Ausgleich von Technik. Das ist der Teil,
wo ich mich mit der Politik auseinandersetze.
Die Inhalte, mit denen setze ich mich ohnehin auseinander. Das macht mir das
alles so leicht und lässt es ein Hobby bleiben.
Und damit, darüber bin ich sehr glücklich, dass ich ein höchst professionelles Hobby haben kann.
Ich hoffe, das korrigiert diesen Eindruck ein bisschen, weil ich gerade so Hobby
als Beruf und so nicht so gut verstanden habe.
Stimmt ja, ist ja auch alles richtig.
War ja auch sehr viel Lob für dich, Tim. Freut mich, dass du mir zustimmst.
Ich meine das ist natürlich auch eine, also das ist natürlich,
jetzt hast du natürlich auch mal einen Einblick gegeben, den wir so glaube ich
auch so noch nicht geteilt haben,
so über unsere Arbeitsverteilung, also wir haben halt immer schon so eine latente
Asymmetrie in dieser Sendungsbespielung, ne?
Du bist sehr viel mehr vor der Sendung involviert,
guckst mehr in die Themen rein, sammelst mehr,
so dann kommen wir halt zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt zusammen,
werfen das sozusagen in so eine Sendungsagenda,
über die wir uns mal mehr, mal weniger intensiv dann noch unterhalten,
bevor wir dann wirklich loslegen, Dann rocken wir halt irgendwie die Sendung
so aus der Hüfte, wie wir das halt irgendwie immer machen.
Und in dem Moment, wo ich hier auf Tschüss gesagt werde und ich meinen Rekordbutton
beende, dann endet sozusagen die Sache für dich dann auch.
Nein, mein Python Skript muss noch die Show Notes machen.
Show Notes wirfst du noch mit rein. Oder irgendein anderes Detail.
Aber ab da beginnt dann eben sozusagen meine wilde Fahrt und dann wird halt
hier geschnitten und publiziert und irgendwie, was halt alles noch so getan
werden muss, bis es dann halt auch wirklich fertig ist.
Manchmal geht es schnell und manchmal dauert es lange.
Wie das halt immer so ist. Naja okay. Aber das ist sozusagen unser Mode und
der funktioniert irgendwie ganz gut und der funktioniert, weil ihr das am Leben erhaltet so.
Weil das ist halt das Ding, dass dieser Support für den ich mich auch herzlich
nochmal bedanken möchte an dieser Stelle,
das ist sozusagen das was es halt alles ermöglicht hat über diese lange Zeit
und ja bisher haben wir keine Pläne da jetzt an dem Plan groß was zu ändern.
Link findet ihr in den Show Notes, ihr könnt Produkte kaufen,
ihr könnt Werbeträger werden von uns.
Stimmt ja, wir haben ja auch noch einen Shop, mein Gott, wir sind echt so schlechte Verkäufer.
Wir haben raumbildende Packmittel mit Einhorn-Standard-Logos,
wir haben T-Shirts mit Einhorn-Standard-Logos, Hoodies, übrigens ich hab beides noch nicht.
Ich freue mich jedes mal total wenn ich das sehe, also ja ich sehe die oft aber
es liegt natürlich auch daran,
dass ich eben im ccc kontext dann doch gerne mal leute sehe oder die halt da auch unsere,
unseren merch tragen, wir haben mit dem logo in weiß auf schwarz,
schwarz auf schwarz, pocket, das zehn jahre shirt das könnten wir mal langsam
durch ein zwölf jahre shirt ersetzen oder so,
Dann müssen wir mal abverkaufen, also sollten wir auf jeden Fall.
Also ihr könnt Shirts kaufen, ihr könnt in der Meta-Ebene ME-Support an die Meta-Ebene spenden,
wenn ihr LNP mit dran schreibt, dann wird das aufgeteilt zwischen Tim und mir, diese Spende.
Natürlich nach Abzug der Betriebskosten, also sowas wie die Meta-Ebene wird
dann natürlich trotzdem daraus finanziert
und dann wird der Rest irgendwie zwischen uns beiden aufgeteilt.
Aber ihr könnt natürlich auch einfach nur mir spenden.
Wer hat euch, wer hat euch heute, wer hat euch besser informiert heute?
Wir haben heute eine sehr gute Aufteilung, oder wir haben eine schöne Aufteilung,
guck mal ich sehe gerade ich habe einen Patreon-Account, habe ich bei mir verlinkt.
Genau wir machen dann immer so ein Button, wer hat die besseren Witze gemacht
und so und dann wird Voting und so.
Ich bin bei, warum spendet mir da keiner? Wahrscheinlich weil ich es noch nie erwähnt habe.
Dann könnte es liegen.
Und Monero und Bitcoin habe ich auch.
Bitcoin, ich bitte dich.
Ich seh das gerade. Ich find das total...
Ich sag mal... Ah, okay, bei Kofi...
Mich wollte gerade so ein Scammer abmahnen, weil ich dieses Bitcoin,
dieses Währungslogo irgendwo auf der Webseite verwendet habe. Das war auch toll.
Der Link war dann irgendwie auch noch falsch und so, aber dann war da irgendwie
so ein Link auf Imgur, wo dieses Bitcoin Ding war.
Auf meiner Webseite gibt es noch ein Bitcoin Logo, wo denn? Da habe ich selber
ein bisschen nachgeguckt, da habe ich gedacht, ah hier, das musst du raus schmeißen.
Jetzt ist alles weg, vielen Dank.
Also ich habe Kofi, da ist mein Goal Millionär, davon bin ich jetzt schon mal
bei 1% laut Kofi und ich habe auch noch ein Stretch Goal, das ist Milliardär,
aber das habe ich da noch nicht ausgelöst.
Genau das hab ich auch, ich guck gerade mal, buy me a coffee gibt's auch,
ich hab mich da schon überall mit der offenen Hand hingestellt ins Internet.
Amazon Wunschzettel, Libera Pay, Libera Pay ist aber gar nicht.
Ja stimmt das hab ich auch noch angeschaltet.
Aber das gibt's gar nicht mehr, weil ich glaub die bitten irgendwas ein und
meine Content Policy vom Webserver verbietet das, also da kann man glaub ich gar nichts klicken.
Aber könnte man auch mal irgendwo, könnte auch mal.
Das ist ja ein bisschen der Segen in Deutschland, wo das irgendwie,
ich meine nicht dass ich behaupten würde in unserem Bankensystem funktioniert
alles, aber so Überweisungen, ihr wisst ja gar nicht wie kompliziert das in
anderen Ländern sein kann, das funktioniert hier noch wunderbar.
Von daher, mein Freund ist der Dauerauftrag.
Und das ist meine Empfehlung nach wie vor, das ist einfach SEPA,
Dauerauftrag, rockt das Haus.
Das ist einfach das Beste, macht das bitte und dann gibt es auch weiterhin Lookbuch
und all die ganzen anderen Verheißungen der Metaebene, frisch auf den Tisch.
So jetzt haben wir aber genug geworben für uns und für die Sache.
Ich versuche gerade mal Monero, jetzt wollen wir was neues runterladen in der Nähe.
Ey dieser ganze Krypto-Kram ist doch jetzt tot oder? Nee Tim das ist sehr gut.
Du weißt nur weil die deutsche Post jetzt die Briefmarken rausbringt geht das nicht mehr los.
Die Briefmarkensammler ab, da geht noch was, ey. Und die brauchen dann auch
noch irgendeinen Die werden schon noch jemanden finden.
Also ich bin guter dinge dass dass ich mit mit konrad reich werde nochmal reich
wie oft man nimmt ja so an dass man irgendwie so am medialen der doofen ist
und schätzt also dass es noch eine ganze menge gibt die nach einem kommen.
Die einsicht dass man halt der letzte doofe war der den scheiß gekauft hat die kommt halt sehr spät.
Ich bin jetzt voll dabei. Ich arbeite an meiner zweiten Million.
Die erste hat nicht geklappt.
Wie viel habe ich Monero? Oh, ach nee, da falle ich jedes Mal drauf ein.
Der stand gerade 142 Euro, aber das ist ein ganzer Monero und ich habe 0,062.
Das läuft richtig für bei dir.
Das heißt, ich habe 8,84 Euro in Monero.
Es läuft richtig bei dir.
So wenn das jetzt exponentiell, kann da nochmal was draus werden. Sonst nicht.
So, genug von Geld gelabert. Ich hoffe die Sendung war nach eurem Geschmack
länger geworden. Hat mir nicht irgendwas von kurze Sendung heute gemurmelt? Guter Witz.
Das ist der Klassiker, wenn wir eine kurze Sendung machen.
Boah, 20h...
Darf ich gar nicht sagen, wie spät es jetzt ist?
Naja, es ist Mittag.
Ja. 20h01.
Sag's einfach, wie es ist.
20h01, Mittag, 20h01. Ja, ist so.
So, wir grüßen euch und wünschen euch einen frohen weiteren Wochenverlauf,
auf das alles so kommt, wie ihr euch das wünscht.
Und wenn nicht, nicht drüber ärgern.
Einfach entspannt bleiben, dann klappt's auch.
Ja, das sind einfach nur die Medien, die euch gegen die Eva Johansson aufhetzen. Das ist alles.
Hat sie doch jetzt gesagt. Also könnt ihr weitergehen. Ist alles nicht so… Genau.
Also bis dann.
Tschau tschau.